if you want to look at that and you
would like to look at that this isn't an
ultrasound no this is a nine week fetus
and a petri dish in a Petri dish it's
just really ghastly to show a picture of
a person who's been killed people such
as yourself like to share propaganda
about this issue and I am here to try to
present a medically accurate
representation what a murder victim of
what this issue is
[Music]
one of the great Sorrows of my life is
that liberals never want to talk to me
me little old me whom everybody loves so
very few want to talk to me I invite
liberals on this show they say no with
some exceptions one of the most
successful popular videos that we've put
out was a debate that I had with a
popular social media influencer on the
left on the topic of abortion who did
have the guts to come on the show and
not only that she did so well that we
decided we had to invite her out here
and that person would be Bronte remsic
Bronte thank you for coming out all the
way to Tennessee and welcome to the
Daily water Studios thank you good to be
here I hope that I can kind of introduce
your viewers to A New Perspective that's
I I you know Isis I suspect they have
been introduced but perhaps you will
change some people's minds for the
occasion I'm having a very pink Drink of
some sort this is my most feminist
quality you are a Bronte a third third
year medical student people can find you
on Tick Tock and throughout social media
and you have a website as well where
you've got all of your ideas and
merchandise yes yes that would be be
kind and curious yes be kind and
curious.com okay
I consider myself kind
I am extremely curious
you have done us the great honor of
coming out here and going through all
the hassle that it takes to get to
Tennessee so you you are staunchly in
favor of abortion I am your captive
audience
if you had to give me the elevator pitch
what would it be absolutely so what I
would really like to start this
conversation off with and make very
clear from the start for both you and
your viewers is I am not saying that you
are wrong for being uncomfortable with
abortion I'm not saying that you are
wrong for not agreeing with it but your
opinion applies to your body and your
life alone we are not sitting here
having a discussion about our personal
disagreements I am here to educate you
and your viewers on the guidelines of
proper Medical Practice that have been
established by our country's leading
medical experts and they have stated
publicly and unequivocally that abortion
access is essential to comprehensive
evidence-based health care and we both
want to protect life and what remains
true is protecting innocent life never
involves restricting access to health
care so
two questions I have from that you
mentioned that all of the genius medical
people agree in our country that we need
to have abortion
now surely all of the genius medical
people have agreed on all sorts of
practices throughout history even in the
not so distant past that are all that
are quite terrible for people one good
example would be lobotomies there was a
scientific consensus in the country that
when women are behaving a little
eccentric we should go in and scramble
up their brains and they use these kinds
of procedures throughout the 20th
century now we look at that as ghastly
and and a violation of basic rights but
this wasn't medical consensus so surely
you're not telling me that just because
a bunch of fancy people in lab coats
think something about a matter of
bioethics that therefore it's the gospel
truth
well a big part of the prior you know
travesties of medicine is there was not
consent from patients and there wasn't
proper informed consent from patients
where when it comes to abortion you
continuously say that I am pro-abortion
when really I am pro-abortion access and
abortion access and the discussion of
having an abortion should be between the
patient and the medical provider and
that is it and the entire concept and
the entire point is that the pregnant
person gets to consent to continue with
their pregnancy and must consent to the
use of their body because they are the
one that understands their body and
their life and their finances and
everything that makes up the
complexities of human life they are the
only ones who are able to decide and
understand what is best for them with
the guidance of you know proper modern
medical practices and it is true that
our world and our country's leading
medical Minds have like I said on
unequivocally stated that abortion
access is essential to comprehensive
evidence-based health care and your
opinion can remain your opinion but it
does not get to override the opinion of
people who train their entire lives to
provide Health Care to people well so on
the matter of consent obviously the
clear rebuttal to that would be that
abortion involves not two people but
three people one of whom is the unborn
baby now I imagine you would have issues
with that description so we can get to
that in a moment the first thing you
said though is that I'm entitled to my
opinion but I'm only entitled to my
opinion as it pertains to my own body
and I'm not entitled to to an opinion
about what you do with your own body but
do you really believe that do you really
believe that people can only have
opinions about things that pertain to
their physical selves I can't have an
opinion about I don't know a sunset or I
don't know how automobiles are made or I
don't know drug use or anything like I
can't have an opinion about politics our
government should be run or how our
political Community ought to behave I
can only have opinions about myself
understand me you can have your opinion
about anything and anyone that you'd
like but that opinion cannot restrict
someone's access to health care you can
agree disagree with someone's choice to
get an abortion but just because you
disagree with it doesn't mean that your
opinion should override the opinion of
their medical experts can can my opinion
be put into effect to restrict someone's
access to drugs like heroin
well in what way well we have
self-government in the United States at
least nominally and so if I think that
heroin is really bad and I think we
ought to have laws against its use then
I can Lobby my elected representatives
and they can pass a law as they have
against heroin and then you are not
allowed to use heroin even though that
affects only your own body I have now
expressed my opinion about heroin in
such a way that restricts what you can
do with your own body are you saying
that that is not acceptable so actually
with laws regarding drugs it is illegal
to buy and sell drugs but it's not
actually illegal to do drugs because you
can't tell depends on the jurisdiction
but true but it you cannot tell me what
I can or cannot do with my body again
you can sit totally and rightfully so
disagree with someone's choice to do
drugs but that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't as health care providers
ensure that that say drug user is able
to make informed choices about their
body are you familiar with like clean
needle programs oh yeah correct and so
clean needle programs they reduce
disease transmission and so even though
someone is going to choose to do drugs
it is the responsibility of medical
experts and health care providers to
ensure that we cannot you know we cannot
change someone's choices and behavioral
patterns but we can ensure that we
provide them resources and able to
ensure that their decisions and the
impact of their decisions is minimized
in whatever way that we can Bronte
putting aside for a moment the efficacy
of clean needle programs which I think
is dubious but that might be a
discussion for another day I think
you're evading the question a little bit
here because you're suggesting that drug
use is not criminal in all cases which
is not the case there are places where
drug use is quite where the use of the
drugs itself is Criminal but even so
let's let's take that let's accept your
premise
nevertheless purchasing the drugs would
be illegal now this is something you do
with your own body with your own money
this is uh it's the very same issue just
removed One Step so is it is it all
right for me to express my opinion about
illicit drug use to restrict you from
doing something that you want to do be
that shooting the heroine purchasing the
heroin putting the heroine in a syringe
whatever you want to say clearly I am
restricting your bodily autonomy here
and that has been done throughout
civilization that remains on the books
in the United States are you saying that
drug laws are basically some sort of
travesty no of course not because it's a
matter of public health now when we talk
about pregnancy and abortion essentially
what causes pregnancy is sex correct and
we cannot Outlaw sex unless that's
something that you are trying to bring
forth and so when it comes to you know
laws limiting someone's ability to have
bodily autonomy or you know limit
someone's ability ability to behave in a
certain way this is sex and pregnancy
and abortion is a very unique
circumstance and sure we can talk all
day about some convoluted you know drug
analogy but at the end of the day well I
know that's your opinion but we cannot
Outlaw sex and sex happens for numerous
reasons and pregnancy can be accidental
and unwanted and so trying to compare it
to illegalizing drug use it's not
completely analogous to illegalizing and
banning abortion because sex and drug
use are two very different things and
they happen for two very different
reasons well I suppose I'm just
discussing the principle that you
described earlier which is that I I
don't have the right to an opinion that
affects what you do with your own body
but even leaving that aside you say that
we can't make sex illegal I don't think
anybody wants to make sex illegal but
historically all sorts of sex has been
illegal and all sorts of sex remains
illegal today there are certain sexual
behaviors Even in our more decadent and
inclusive age that are illegal obviously
sex with children or sex with animals
things like that historically sex
outside of marriage has been illegal in
many places homosexual sexual activities
have been illegal in many places so
we've had laws in the United States and
continue to have laws that regulate sex
uh all of that though I wonder so
historically you know those are the
facts and doesn't that seem to be a
little bit beside the point when it
comes to abortion because now we're
saying no that you know of consenting
adults above the age of 18 they can have
all the sex they want but if you do have
sex and you do get pregnant well you
don't have the right to kill the baby
well when you talk about things like you
know having sex with children or animals
being illegal that's because they can't
properly consent to have sex where when
we're talking about consent or sex with
con you know consensual sex between
adults that happens for multiple reasons
people have sex for social reasons um
social connections psychological reasons
not just for the reason of procreation
and so short pregnancy can happen
accidentally and unwanted but consent
must be enthusiastic and ongoing and so
when we talk you know what if it's only
timid tepid consent you know sort of law
well I'll do it but you know I'm not
yeah I mean that's a really big problem
in our society right now and you know
that's something that people will take
you know the smaller you know people
will push people to say yes and that's
when that's why we say sex should be
enthusiastic and ongoing because if you
are trying to have sex with someone
who's not enthusiastic about it then
maybe you should second guess your
choices but isn't that a bit I agree
with you entirely but isn't that a bit
sexy negative of you to say that that
there is a certain way that one should
engage in consensual sex I mean no you
don't think so no because enthusiasm is
expressed you know differently between
people it doesn't mean that you have to
be jumping up and down I just mean that
the person who's consenting is
consenting you know very clearly and
enthusiastically in their own way and
not being pressured into saying yes not
being timid about saying yes you know
you are ensuring that they are saying
yes you know out of their own validity
and when we talk I want to compare like
sex with pregnancy right because we're
talking about consent so you understand
that sex can be a fun and beautiful
thing without you know people do for
lots of different reasons but it's only
fun and beautiful when it's consensual
and when sex is not consensual it can be
traumatic and devastating for people
sure the same thing for pregnancy when
pregnancy is consensual and pregnancy is
wanted it can be a beautiful thing but
when pregnancy is unwanted and
non-consensual then it can be a very
very traumatic and devastating thing
well you know I suspect it can be
both in either case I mean I think not
only of the experience of my wife but of
many of my friends who have had kids and
and they want kids and they
intentionally get pregnant or at least
they are happy when they find out that
they accidentally become pregnant but
there's still a lot of trauma involved
in that I mean there's a lot of
suffering that comes along with that
that's part of pregnancy and childbirth
and life generally you know life
involves some degree of suffering so
it just seems what you're saying is when
when the pregnancy is desired that is
beautiful and we should celebrate it and
when the pregnancy is not desired then
you ought to be able to end it and
meaning end the little baby and it
reminds me of what the you see this with
the Royal Family
the royal family you know the princess
gets pregnant they say we have the royal
baby the baby's only 10 weeks in
gestation but they say this is a royal
baby but then some left-wing woman goes
on television and says you know I just
had an abortion well that's never a baby
that's just a clump of cells but we're
talking about the exact same thing right
we're talking about a child at who knows
15 weeks gestation 20 weeks gestation
let's say so
yes I I understand that the experience
of sex and pregnancy can be felt
differently in different circumstances
but the baby himself would be the same
in both circumstances it's just in one
we celebrate his beautiful baby life and
in the other we kill him as a clump of
cells
when it comes to medical terminology
It's actually an embryo or a fetus
when you call it a clump of cells I
agree that that can feel dehumanizing
but on the same side when you call it a
baby that's also anthropomorphizing so I
think that right and so that's neither
side is correct in its entirety and that
doesn't remove what well I guess the
you're you're entirely right that the
land I mean you mentioned the word fetus
which which ironically is dehumanizing
although the word fetus you know the
Latin word fetus just means Offspring
and we're referring human beings here
but doesn't the question hinge on
which language should we use so one is
dehumanizing one is anthropomorphizing
in other words humanizing so then isn't
the question that we have to answer
is this thing that we're talking about a
human or not and if it is a human then
we should only use the
anthropomorphizing language and if it is
not a human then we should only call
them a clump of cells well when it comes
to medicine and Medical Practice it is
you are you call it a fetus and the
reason I don't call it a fetus well but
you're also not a medical professional
but I'm a human being with rational
faculty right who describes the world
around him right true but you aren't
having discussions with pregnant people
and when
as a medical professional so there are
articles written for medical
professionals how about how to have
these conversations and it is
appropriate to call it a fetus and when
the pregnancy is wanted it is also
appropriate to call it a baby when that
pregnancy is wanted and desired and you
are trying to create a comforting and
accepting environment for that pregnant
person but from a medical standpoint it
is completely appropriate to call it a
fetus until you understand where your
patient is at in their mentality
regarding their practice is that is that
guidance that doctors get if the if the
mother wants to be pregnant then you can
call it a baby but if the mother doesn't
want to be pregnant you don't call it a
baby
it depends that's amazing that that's
the medical guidance yeah well it's all
about creating a comfortable and
appropriate environment for the patient
because we care about the mentality of
the patient and you want the patient to
be able to make an informed choice you
want the patient to feel comfortable in
your exam room and if calling it a fetus
when it is a wanted pregnancy can make
them feel detached from that pregnancy
but also calling it a baby when it is an
unwanted pregnancy can put you know
unnecessary pressure and fear onto that
brain but you you don't believe that
whether or not the baby is human hinges
on whether or not the mother desires the
baby or fetuses you don't think that the
desire is the determining factor for the
ontology of
the embryo the embryo is human that's
that's not within question it is a human
embryo so then why wouldn't you use
anthropomorphizing language why wouldn't
you refer to it in human language
because language is often emotional and
pregnancy is an emotional state for
someone to be in and as a medical
professional you have to be conscious of
the way that your words affect the
patient and so you would lie to the
patient because you're just lying well
you said it is lying because you said
the baby or fetus or whatever you want
to say is a human and you said the word
baby is humanizing language so you're
describing the human being with
humanizing language unless you say that
the emotions of the of the pregnant
mother are such that you don't want to
describe the human being in humanizing
language and so you describe the human
being in dehumanizing language how do
you and you're doing it knowingly you've
just admitted the baby's human yeah how
would you describe that other than
telling a lie
I didn't say that anthropomorphizing was
necessarily a negative thing and as I
said saying fetus is medical terminology
and it is appropriate it is appropriate
but it should be humanizing you said no
call in a clump of cells is dehumanized
calling it a fetus is not dehumanizing
it's medically appropriate and it's
medically
consistent with how you should you know
Define then why the distinction why why
do why do are you given the guidance to
call it a fetus to the woman who doesn't
want the baby and a baby to the woman
who does want the baby I've I've
explained this to you but I can explain
it maybe I'm just a little slow that's
okay I'll slow it down for you then it
depends on the mentality of the pregnant
person and how
towards that pregnancy
in that exam room you are trying to
create a comfortable environment where
that patient understands what their
options are and what their situation is
and so when you are trying to identify
how they feel about their current
medical State you want to use language
that creates a comfortable environment
for them so how do those two words
affect their emotional statement what is
the what what is the reason for the
distinction when a pregnant mother who
doesn't want the baby hears you describe
the baby as a fetus versus as a baby how
are they per how are they perceiving and
conceiving of that so I can probably ask
you the same question Michael why on
your show and in these interviews do you
insist on calling it a baby is it
because you understand the emotional
pull that that has on your viewers so
you insist on using that language it
doesn't understand it's emotional no
well no it's because I I think it's
ontologically precise in exactly the way
you just described because you say that
the word baby is anthropomorphizing and
you said that the human being inside you
is a human being and so it's appropriate
to use humanizing language for human
beings
depending on the conversation that you
are having because you have to be aware
and compassionate towards the person
that you are having that discussion
right but I don't think it's
compassionate to deceive people or to
pretend that the human isn't a human I
think that always disrespectful to lie
to people calling it a fetus isn't lying
calling it a fetus but it's it's less
anthropomorphizing than baby you would
admit it's medically appropriate but
would you admit that it's less
humanizing than the word baby
less humanizing yes it's a human penis
it's a human fetus it is so so if the if
the two words are synonymous why is
there guidance for one and then the
other what you keep saying it's because
of the emotional state of the mother
yeah but okay how is that perceived how
are how how do the emotions change
hearing one word or the other
hey baby why why do you choose to say
baby instead of fetus because it's well
because there's an emotional no because
it's precise because there's an
emotional baggage that comes with baby
and so if because it's plain language
and so I I generally try not to use sort
of Latin or jargony terms for things
that are plainly understood and so
that's why I prefer good Saxon words and
good plain words and I don't use a 25
cent word when I can use a nickel word
and as you just said to to the the
guidance to um use one word or the other
based on whether the mother wants to
have an abortion or wants to give birth
to her child clearly though you don't
don't seem willing to admit it but
clearly is because the word fetus allows
this pregnant mother in distress to
abstract away the humanity of her child
and makes it easier for that woman to
justify having an abortion whereas if
she were to call it a baby it would be
much much harder for her to justify
killing the baby in the womb through
abortion right that's I think you would
acknowledge that yeah I can acknowledge
that calling it a baby minimizes the
options that the pregnant person feels
like they have and it can put unwanted
pressure onto them and if they are not
in a financial mental or physical state
to carry through with that pregnancy
appropriately calling in a baby makes
them feel as if they have less options
than they truly do and should have so
you you mentioned those three states
that you might be in where you you don't
want it where you want to kill your
child
a Financial State psychological State
and what was the other one physical
state
so I I understand the psychological
state so let's put that to the side for
a second we can get to it later
what is the financial and physical state
that would require one or greatly impel
one to end their baby's life in the womb
through abortion do you know how much it
costs to
carry through with pregnancy all through
well yeah please please it's not that
it's actually not that expensive it's
not cheap but it's not to to you it's
not that expensive but can how expensive
how expensive is it well you just went
through it with your wife right you need
to buy some prenatal vitamins you know
you got to go to some doctor visits so
it's good to have health care though
we're very lucky in this country that uh
the very poor have health care through
Medicaid and uh the elderly well I guess
they don't get pregnant all that much
but they could have Medicare and people
have health insurance through their
employers and there is a public option
in recent years and people can stand
their parents Healthcare until the age
of 26. so we have also and you can go to
an emergency room whenever you want so
there are all sorts of healthcare
options in the United States some of
which could be improved and we could
maybe get to that later but there are
lots of health care options in the
United States and then when one delivers
in the hospital there is a very large
sticker price I mean it'll say thirty
thousand fifty thousand dollars but
people don't really pay that price
because insurance covers that and it's
also basically just a scam to enrich the
insurance companies but that's again
another problem with you US Health Care
System people aren't actually writing
fifty thousand dollar checks to give
birth to their children so you know I'm
not saying it's cheap to eat well and be
able to stay home on bed rest perhaps if
the doctor requires that or to get
prenatal vitamins or to raise a kid is
very very expensive I'm not I'm not
doubting any of that but to just get to
the point of delivering the baby and
then perhaps giving the baby up for
adoption is not very expensive so
actually I'll correct you there so it
costs about eighteen thousand dollars on
average to carry through with a
pregnancy and I've only gotten a good
deal then yeah so and with it if you
have insurance the out-of-pocket cost is
around two to three thousand dollars but
what you might not understand either
which I you know work in the medical
field in rural North Carolina so I'm
very much familiar with people who they
do not have insurance or cannot afford
insurance whether through their employer
or if they're contract workers it just
depends and then the limit for someone
to be qualified for Medicaid there is a
good amount of people that fall in
between there and I worked at a clinic
that offered free care to people who
were uninsured but don't qualify for
Medicaid and our Clinic was busy all the
time because there is a massive amount
of people who fall in that area there's
a great a great organization called good
Council homes which I I really love it's
a pregnancy center up in Connecticut and
they do fabulous work for people who
again might fall through the cracks or
might be very distressed and and for
whom abortion might seem attractive
because of that Financial reason but
there are lots and lots of these
organizations you mentioned the one that
you work with I mentioned the one that
I've done some work with and there are
many many others around the country
which is which is good that's a fact to
be celebrated but it seems to undermine
the argument that uh financial reasons
impel people to get abortions no because
we as we discussed in the beginning
there's multiple reasons that someone
might not be able to carry through with
a pregnancy physically psychologically
and financially and financially the
financial aspect of it cannot be
belittled let's be serious I think but I
think you're you're overstating it right
that's your opinion but for many my
opinion with experience I've got two
kids under my belt hoping for more you
know so they've actually found that
about 40 percent of Americans cannot
afford an unexpected 400 cost whether
that be for their home for their health
or whatever and so saying that it's not
a big deal to inquire about if you have
insurance about a two to three thousand
dollar costs and if you don't have
insurance it can be about 18 000 on
average when forty percent of Americans
can't afford an unexpected 400 cost you
are basically discounting the experience
well the authority is I think what are
those statistics though is they're not
quite right because uh it's true that
many Americans don't have a lot of money
like cash available but Americans tend
to have a lot of stuff because Americans
carry a lot of debt so those numbers are
also somewhat misleading because of what
people do is go into debt or in the if
we're talking about something like an
adoption which is what we're really what
we're really discussing here uh there
are all sorts of wonderful adoption
agencies and all sorts of wonderful
programs provided by the state and
provided by private charity that cover
these costs for all sorts of people who
are financially strapped but don't want
to kill their children and so I I just
think it's a an an argument to evade the
basic question I promise you if you and
I'll say it to the camera right now if
you are pregnant and you feel that you
can't afford to carry your child through
pregnancy and you can't afford the 500
and you can't find an organization that
will cover it write to me I will write
that check happily and it's not just me
plenty of pro-life people around the
country would do it that's why they do
it that's why they give to these
organizations do you you really believe
five hundred to two thousand dollars is
uh that that Delta that people might may
or may not be able to afford is is a
strong justification for killing 850 000
human beings every year so again saying
the term killing 800 000 human beings no
that that is using manipulative and
emotional language you said that the
fetus is a human being that's that
wasn't my language that's your language
okay but killing a human being is not
the same as aborting a fetus but you can
use the manipulative and emotional
language if you'd like I'm really using
your language because you said that the
it's alive and it's a human being and so
what do you call it when you end a life
it's just killing that's just the
precise way to describe it and what do
you call a human being as a human being
so I said you're killing a human being
that's your language
if that's how you'd like to describe it
that's fine that's how you described it
well since we've talked about the
financial aspects of abortion and
pregnancy why don't we talk about the
physical and mental aspects of it
because that is really the heart of the
bodily autonomy argument sure sure so
that the physical uh issue
uh
I don't need to recite these statistics
for you the percentage of women who get
abortions because the baby poses a
direct threat to their lives
it's a very small number and far less
than one percent by direct threat to
their lives you mean they're going to
lose their life yep okay well Michael do
you know what the leading cause of death
for pregnant people is
pregnant people
mothers women if you'd like to call them
mothers not all of them are mothers but
if you'd like to call them that what are
they if they're not mothers they're
pregnant people
what what people other than mothers are
pregnant
bother you to use inclusive language
it's just interesting I prefer to use
precise language it's interesting
because you come into this conversation
you know trying to hold this moral
superiority but then when I when I try
to be moral when I can but I right but
when I use inclusive language which it
only takes a couple extra syllables to
use inclusive language and it seems to
include people who don't clap you know
identify as women but can become
pregnant
so
like a person who's born a woman and
then identifies as a man and is pregnant
yeah so you're telling me that in order
to be a moral person I need to accept
the idea that a man
someone who is born a man who looks like
a man can really become a woman that's
that's a prerequisite of my being a
moral person
I mean yes to me it is because if you
are trying to deny someone of their
identity and deny what their life
experience is then that doesn't seem
like a moral stance to me I want to be
accepting and I want to respect people's
life experiences and respect the way
that they want to identify and respect
the way that they want to present
themselves to the world I would like to
identify I do identify actually as the
correct person on this issue of abortion
I identify as being correct and more
correct than you on this issue and I
would just ask that you accept and
affirm my identity do you well you are
not a medical professional an abortion
and pregnancy
that's not your identity that is my I
promise you that's my identity I promise
you that that's very different from your
sexual and gender identity how so what
what I'm talking here involves the mind
I mean don't you think I'm not just
talking about my gonads or something
like that I'm talking about I'm not just
talking about my sexual appetites or
desires I'm talking about my my mind my
capacity for reason my judgment here and
so you're saying you don't respect that
identity but you do respect the identity
of a man who believes himself to be a
woman I'm saying that you are someone
without medical training and pregnancy
is a medical condition and abortion is a
medical procedure and so we need to
abide by the informed and knowledgeable
opinions of medical experts again you
are entitled to your opinion but you are
not an informed and knowledgeable
medical expert so your opinion is not
equal and should not override the
opinions of medical experts on this
issue and they have stated unequivocally
that abortion access is essential to
comprehensive evidence-based Health Care
Bronte do you are you a trained
epistemologist
no you haven't studied epistemology no
and yet you are making claims about
knowledge and how knowledge can be
ascertained and expressed
but you're not trained in that so it
seems to me if I'm not allowed to have
opinions about abortion because I'm not
a trained Medical Professional you
surely shouldn't be permitted to have
opinions about how people hold opinions
if you're not trained in the very study
of knowledge epistemology I'm sorry if
you have a heart condition who do you go
to do you go to your Deli worker or do
you go to a cardiologist but if you have
a philosophical question who do you go
to this isn't a philosophical question
this is a question about it's a question
about medical access this is a question
about medical access no well ultimately
what we're talking about is human life
right I mean that is that's that's the
reason it's a controversial issue
well yes but also pregnant people are
living human lives so we we are talking
about their life and their life takes
precedent when it comes to medical care
well that that's you now you've moved
out of the realm of the Natural Sciences
now you're into the realm of the
philosophical no no this this is a
fundamental principle of medical ethics
is a fundamental point of ethics of
medical ethics right which is a which is
a species of Ethics broadly but but you
just said you're not a trained ethicist
you're not well you said you're not a
trained epistemologist maybe you're a
trained ethicist are you I I'm trained
in medicine and we've had to take
multiple courses in medical ethics I
have my Master's in medical science I'm
a third year medical student not but not
ethics or philosophy we have to take I
don't know if you know this but at when
you are going through medical training
you are trained in ethics because
otherwise no I should hope I mean I
should hope that anybody who has any
education at all would have some
training in ethics yeah that's true
exactly but but you're you're would you
call yourself an expert in ethics and I
would call myself knowledgeable and also
I would call myself right but to be
clear as I said at the beginning of this
discussion we're we're not sitting here
just having a discussion about our
differences and opinion I am here to
educate you and your viewers on the
guidelines and the published statements
of our country's leading medical experts
specifically not even just the
unpublished ones but the published ones
but the published ones the public
published opinions of the American
College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists who is our country's
leading experts when it comes to the
health and well of pregnant people and
they say unequivocally and you can look
there's also Publications from Harvard
from Colorado University from Yale name
it all our countries our country's
leading Minds our country's leading
Minds state that abortion access is
essential so you are entitled to your
opinion but it is not equal to the
opinion of people who train their entire
lives to understand the subject deeply
well if we're citing experts and the
leading authorities I I would I would be
remiss if I didn't cite the president's
Council on bioethical inquiry which in
the middle of the 2000s assembled to the
nation's leading experts on bioethical
questions from all of the top schools
with all of the fanciest degrees and
they concluded that abortion is
bioethically unacceptable it's immoral
it's wrong you can't do it so I'm not
quite sure why I'm supposed to trust the
trade organization of American
Obstetricians over the The bioethicists
Who certainly have far more expertise in
this realm of knowledge than the
Obstetricians who might be very good at
delivering babies but might not be quite
as as good at understanding matters of
ethics and morality so Obstetricians and
gynecologists specialize in the health
and well-being of pregnant people and
pregnancy affects the health and
well-being of pregnant people it also
affects the babies correct but when it
comes to looking at a pregnant person
their health when it comes to you know a
medical condition that it is between the
life of the pregnant person and ending
the pregnancy the life of the pregnant
person takes precedent unless otherwise
specified by the pregnant person because
consent is everything so oh so so you're
saying that the life of the mother
takes precedent unless the mother says
no Ida okay
now again the only reason I keep
bringing up this matter of bioethics is
that statement that you're making is not
a statement that pertains to Natural
Science it's in the way that I would say
you know if you want to get a baby out
you use this clamp or you know if you
want to make an incision into an abdomen
you use this sort of knife or this
instrument
when you say so and so's life takes
precedence over someone else's life that
is that is a philosophical statement and
it's an ethical statement which is
different than a statement about you
know Natural Science you know this glass
is made up of certain chemicals or
whatever uh so that's that's why I think
you're conflating those two Realms here
and you're trying to trade expertise
from one realm in the Natural Sciences
into expertise in another realm which
would be philosophy and ethics and I'm
I'm all for trying to bring these things
together in in a you know University
style way you know you bring knowledge
together because everything affects
everything else but I think it's just
disingenuous to claim then that
Obstetricians or the be all and end-all
authorities on on every single matter
it's also where worth pointing out these
threats to the life of the mother are
threats to her actual life or
exceptionally rare I mean far less than
one percent of people who have abortions
do sebias a threat to the life of the
mother there is no medical condition for
which that the treatment is abortion
actually incorrect but also um as I
asked you before do you know the leading
cause of death for pregnant people I
assume it's some
comorbidity of you know I don't know
obesity or heart disease or
something involving preeclampsia I don't
know it's actually homicide homicide is
the number one cause of death for
pregnant people one cause of death for
babies and abortion too
it is but we are talking about living
breathing people who are people's
daughters sisters mothers did you know
59 of people who get abortions already
have children and so we're talking about
them prioritizing their needs and their
life and you trying to limit their
ability to care for their already
existing children and the number one
cause of death for pregnant people you
do because you know being able to afford
medical care for pregnancy and labor
takes away from their ability to care
for their already existing children it
costs a lot of money to raise children
so if we're talking about 500 here or
there which again I think we already
pointed out can be taken care of through
any number of organizations through the
state and through private charity but if
you know we're talking about the
difference of 500 here the cost of
raising a child to the age of 18 is
enormous it's hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars correct and so
if you're uh if if you won't be able to
raise your children because of a 500
cost then you're not going to raise your
children anyway
right you can't afford to raise them
anyway because the total cost is just
five a 500 cost is what the average cost
of an abortion the average cost of
pregnancy and labor is 18 000 without
insurance about 3 000 with insurance and
so I I don't you know again I see that
you see yourself as a compassionate and
moral person but in order I don't know
that I see myself that way but I
certainly strive it doesn't seem so when
you try to consistently minimize these
hardships that people are encountering
and you say it's not that much it's not
that big no I I just think that uh it is
uh better for a mother to endure the
discomfort and cost of pregnancy uh than
it is for her to murder her child is
really what I think that's your opinion
but it's also it's also not your right
to decide what the what the amount of
risk someone should take what amount of
harm they should endure without their
why is that not my right why is it not
your right to decide what sort of risk
that I should take over my body yeah why
is that not my right because it is my
body and I get to decide what kind of
health risks that I accept but we've
already established that that in
especially in a self-governing republic
we pass all sorts of laws that restrict
people's bodily autonomy like drug laws
so so why is it not my why is it my
right to pass a law against you you
about you using heroin but not my right
to pass a law that prevents you from
murdering your child for that matter we
live in a self-governing republic we
have laws against murder that limits
what people can do with their own bodies
to somebody else in exactly the same way
that a law against abortion would limit
what you can do with your own body to
another human being can you tell me a
scenario where you can force someone to
use their body to save the life of
another individual of a situation other
than motherhood
uh no no I think motherhood is unique
okay so you can't describe any other
scenario where one human can be forced
against their will to use their body to
save the life of another person well I
don't know I mean they're they're
I wouldn't be opposed to a law that says
you know if there's if you see a little
kid drowning in a pool you have an
obligation to jump in the pool and pull
the kid out I mean I think that would be
perfectly reasonable that's not the same
thing as using your internal organs and
body well that's different yeah your
internal organs that would be unique to
Motherhood yeah right and so the fact
that there is no other scenario where
you can force a living person to use
their body to save the life of another
person means that you are trying to
Grant fetus's rights that no other
person on this no I think you're right
to describe motherhood as a singular
phenomenon yeah it is it is unique and
motherhood is something that half of the
population can possibly experience and
the fact that there is half the
population that will never have the
possibility of experiencing that it's a
great pity for us
makes it so that when you are pushing
for abortion bans it is essentially a
sexist issue and you are creating that
you know that the pro-life movement is
mostly women and you know that women are
split 50 50 on the issue also it's not
pro-life it is anti-choice because if
you actually whatever language you want
to use the movement against abortions
the movement against abortion is mostly
women and women are split basically 50
50 in America on the issue so so to call
it sexist or misogynist or whatever
seems a little bit silly you're trying
it would seem to me that you are
describing this as you know the men
forcing this on the women but that just
if you look at the makeup of the
movement against abortion I call it the
pro-life movement and you look at the
the public opinion on abortion among
women is mostly women so the peer
research center actually did surveys and
found that 61 of Americans feel that
abortion should be accessible in all or
most cases 29 of Americans found that it
should be accessible in cases of rape
incest or to protect the life of the
mother and nine percent of Americans
thought those numbers don't seem to
you're saying 61 of Americans say it
should be available in all cases and 29
say it should be available for victims
of rape
rape incest or for the life of the
mother why is that number small I would
imagine that the number would say well
certainly women who you know if face an
existential risk from pregnancy they
should be able to have abortion but
wouldn't you expect that number to be
higher
if you were misreading the statistics
because it doesn't seem credible to me
no you can look it up it's on the Pew
research it's by the Pew Research Center
and they found that strange why would
the number go down for a more dire
situation no 29 of Americans think that
it should only be oh understood only be
accessible in those scenarios and so I
just want to make it clear that 29 of
Americans think that it should only be
accessible for in cases of rape incest
or
um the risk of life for the mother and
so you are and I I understand that that
might not even be the category that you
find yourself in and only nine percent
of Americans believe that it should
never be legal and so I just want to
make it clear that you are in the
minority on this issue the problem
viewers might be as well the problem
with the statistics though Bronte is
that I mean I'll just take your word for
it on the Pew numbers but you can look
at any number of polls on this issue
from Pew to Gallup to Harvard Harris to
all of these other people and so I can
find one poll I think it was Gallop but
I forget which one it was that shows
that only six percent of Americans
believe that abortion should be illegal
in all circumstances 94 of Americans
believe that there should be some
restrictions on abortion and when you
get even more granular on it you look at
the way that the questions are phrased
the the numbers become even more
malleable so you know there are lies
damned lies and statistics I think just
if you look at the way that people vote
you look at the way that you look at the
way that people uh Express their views
through their elected representatives on
questions of abortion it is roughly
split that's why it's been a contentious
issue for a very long time and uh and so
you know you can I suppose you can have
your statistics from your credible
Research Institute and I guess I'll have
mine yeah you know it's really easy to
just discount statistics when you
disagree no but you're discounting my
statistics well you didn't give me a
source you didn't give me I did scallop
but I could be wrong my resources are
actually they're also from Gallup Pew
and Gallup Pew and Gallup they published
uh very similar numbers oh interesting
well I suppose I'll I suppose I'll just
have to go look it up yeah but I
encourage your viewers too as well
because I really just want to reiterate
that you know you you feel like this is
a 50 50. America is really split when
really we are not 61 of Americans feel
that abortion should be accessible in
all or most cases that is the majority
of Americans but but Bronte the the
thing is and again
by my statistics you know that those
numbers are very different and by the
statistics of the pro-lifer site but but
even if that were the case let's say
it's 61 okay 61 or pro-abortion for
sixty percent of pro-abortion 40 are are
anti-abortion
so what
it's still it's still you know it's
still roughly split though by your
numbers that's obviously much more
favorable to the pro-abortion side but
but so what I mean that doesn't
you know the mob of people killed
Socrates the mob of people chose
Barabbas are we really saying that the
the uh
measure of right and wrong is some
conveniently selected public opinion
poll well if you would like another
statistic 95 well I'll give it to you
anyways more than welcome to give it to
you you're welcome 95 of OB gyns say
that they would assist a patient in
receiving an abortion regardless of
their personal feelings about it so
where I where I praise so on lbgyn could
think that that what he or she is doing
is actually murdering a baby and then
that person would do it anyway
because wow I I certainly don't trust
that person's judgment goodness gracious
it is because of their and that's why I
bring it up because when we look at the
people in our society who are trained to
care for the health and well-being of
pregnant people even they understand
95 of them understand that their
personal feelings about this matter
cannot override and should not override
a patient's ability to access
comprehensive medical so why do they
have those personal feelings at all
because your opinion was you know is
about your body and your life alone
exactly but
as I said before the leading cause of
death for pregnant people is homicide
and I bring that up because you cannot
pretend like you understand the
situations that people find themselves
in people's lives so what you're telling
me is that if a woman is threatened with
Murder by her boyfriend
uh because the boyfriend doesn't want
her to be pregnant or something like
that uh that uh that is why we need to
uh basically give those women the option
to kill their baby
because they're psychopath boyfriends
might murder them if they don't murder
their own child that's what you're
telling me the solution is to these
murderous boyfriends that you're
describing are you minimizing the threat
to someone's life oh I just think that I
don't think the the solution to a
boyfriend threatening to kill a
girlfriend if she doesn't kill her own
child is to encourage the girlfriend to
kill her own child we're not encouraging
her we are giving her the access to that
option wouldn't it be better to send in
the Civil authority to arrest the
murderous boyfriend and protect the
mother and the child in a perfect world
yes but we don't live in that world what
if the mother who is afraid of being
murdered by her boyfriend wants to keep
her child but she's afraid that she's
going to get murdered so she feels that
it'll just be sort of safer for her to
go kill the child even if this there was
a video of this that just went viral
recently of a clearly abusive boyfriend
who was trying to throw his pregnant
girlfriend into a car to go get an
abortion it went viral I think about six
months or so ago and the woman clearly
doesn't want to get the abortion and the
boyfriend really wants her too it's the
exact situation that you were describing
you think that the solution to that is
to make it easier for the woman to get
the abortion to make it easier to give
the murderous boyfriend what he wants
what I am saying well no because this
entire thing is about consent it's about
the I don't think it's about consent I
think you don't seem to respect consent
no I think consensus well you think it's
the heart of the issue I think the
baby's heart is the heart of the issue I
think the baby's life is the heart of
this and you think consent plays a role
in moral judgments but it's not the only
Criterion that we consider when we come
to moral decisions so can I ask you why
do you find it so easy to have
compassion for a fetus or a baby that is
non-autonomous and has absolutely no
awareness of its own existence but you
find it so difficult to expand expand
that compassion towards pregnant people
well no I don't think it's good for
pregnant people also known as mothers to
kill their children I don't think it's
good for them I don't think it's good
for the children I also would have to
push back on your your argument that
babies in the womb do not have any
awareness they do have some awareness
and they do react to their uh their
environments they can kick and they can
move and they can when when the mother
eats something that's maybe a little
spicy the baby will actually get hiccups
and things like that and when you
describe I don't know self-awareness I
mean yeah it's true the baby in the womb
does not have consciousness
you know what is it not going to
discourse on you know Aristotle or
something but a six-month-old baby isn't
really conscious either right certainly
a newborn baby
no more Consciousness than the baby in
the womb does their conscious just not
aware but also
I mean what do you mean by consciousness
first of all are you aware when we can
talk about different numbers but are you
aware of the time in which an 80 of
abortions take place like the state of
gestation yeah that's a relatively early
first trimester okay do you know the
week perhaps I don't know okay so 80 of
abortions occur before week nine and you
know you say that their babies are
kicking and reacting are you aware of
what a nine-week-old fetus looks like oh
yes very well yes can you describe it to
me yeah yeah well by a really I suppose
by the 10th week that's that's uh you
know especially when you go in and you
have your babies you go in for an
eight-week appointment by the eight week
appointment they can tell you the sex of
of your baby which is amazing that's how
well formed they are already by the
10-week appointment they've got
basically all of their features formed
in a very rudimentary way but they're
already quite formed and you can you can
look and they no longer look like a
little tadpole entirely they look much
more like a human being really and
they've got their little fingers already
in their little toes
I actually have pictures for you right
so
this is nine weeks
this is what a nine week fetus looks
like well let me see I would like to if
you want to look at that and you would
like to look at that
you can look at this oh great yeah yeah
and I know that you it's not like any
ultrasound I've ever looked at though
yeah I know that's why I brought them
because this isn't an ultrasound no this
is a nine week fetus and a petri dish in
a Petri dish why do you have the thing
in the petri dish
to Discount misinformation that is
spread about this issue but just like
you do how did the baby get into the
petri dish it's I believe these are
aborted
and so this so you're saying that a baby
that has been sucked out and dismembered
looks a little bit different they aren't
abort they aren't dismembered because
there isn't enough of them the fetus is
barely recognizable to the naked eye how
is that baby aborted so at nine weeks
it's usually just a pill that expels the
fetus what does the pill all the pill
does is expel a bit Yeah it basically
makes the uterine lining not able to um
or the fetus not able to adhere to the
uterine lining and itch that's it it's
there's various mechanisms so the there
are what are some of the other
mechanisms
well it depends on the week of gestation
let's say around 10 weeks we're talking
about so I think after 10 weeks is they
what they will do is it's no longer
going to be a pill they essentially
um inject like saline solution and they
inject in it it removes it from the
uterine lining so a it's a basically a
poison no no it's flushing it's cleaning
out the uterus but it but it's uh
yeah I'm not saying it's cyanide or
something like that but it's you're
injecting a chemical into the uterus
usually like saline solution right but I
can if I put saline solution on a slug
it'll shrivel up and die yeah are you a
slug
do humans react the same way the saline
solution is slugs too yes little babies
do actually no they just that's why it
connects it no so this is to resolve the
connection between the mother between
the baby and the placenta and the mother
so and to flush out the poor little baby
so this is why I think it's really
ghastly and disingenuous of you to to no
I'm great I'm bringing this because you
consistently want to anthropomorphize
this issue you described the baby as
anthropomorphic you describe the baby as
a human
you did you said it's a human being it
is a human being but you know you're
accusing me of anthropomorphizing a
human being is a nine week old fetus
this is a nine week old fetus and I
bring this to try to address
misinformation about can I if you would
please allow me sure it's just really
ghastly to show a picture of a person
who's been killed and I apologize for
that but I do this apology implies that
you'll correct your behavior no not
doing that because people such as
yourself and there are different
multiple different websites that like to
share propaganda about this issue and I
am here to try to present a medically
accurate representation
of what this issue is and when you try
to act as though it is murder I want
your audience to truly truly understand
what we are talking about because I am
not saying that a woman with a desired
pregnancy shouldn't feel connected to
her fetus that's not what I'm saying I
am saying when we are having when we
have a person with an unwanted pregnancy
you cannot act as though their choice to
you know decide what is best for their
life and their body is murder when in
reality it is a living person standing
in front of you who's a living breathing
person with dreams and aspirations who
is a mother sister you know a daughter
wasn't no 59 of people who get abortions
are mothers with existing children and
so I just all of them have existing
children
foreign
what's so confusing about this to me and
what's very silly I think about showing
pictures of aborted babies is it would
be as though if you were to ask me to
show you a picture of uh you know what
is an Italian guy in New York look like
okay and I showed you a picture of of a
of a young 25 year old Italian guy
splayed out on the street chopped up
bleeding dead
versus uh you know an Italian boy uh you
know eating a bowl of spaghetti or
something like that those two pictures
would look very very different and so
what the the trick the deception that
you've engaged in is you've taken a baby
who has been killed through abortion and
been separated from his mother and
splayed out and squeezed out and and
looks unrecognizable and you're
pretending no that that and you're what
you're pretending is that that cadaver
is uh what a baby who has not been
killed by his mother who is still in the
womb and who is growing and who's
exhibiting all the signs of life and it
was moving and it has little fingernails
no this was expelled it was not
dismembered if you look at this
primarily most of the tissue here is the
gestational Sac because the beginnings
of pregnancy the gestational sac and the
placenta are where some of the first
things created because that is what
attaches to the uterine lining and
provides the fetus with resources and
expels its waste that is primarily in
the first few weeks of pregnancy those
are the tissue contents that are created
before the fetus is really developed in
a nine week old fetus like I have here
the fetus itself is hardly
distinguishable to the human eye because
it's so small because it's so small and
so that is why I bring it up because so
hold on then because when you present
this you say well actually this mostly
isn't the fetus this mostly is all this
other stuff okay but then you're not
showing me what a fetus looks like the
fetus is in this picture right but just
remember it's very very small that is
how so how much of that picture is the
fetus it is indistinguishable to the
human eye oh so so now all you're saying
is the fetus at that stage it's not that
uh
it's not that the fetus
you know looks like all this tissue
actually isn't really the fetus because
you you can't even see the feet exactly
but you can't really see it so now
you're what you're admitting is you're
not showing people a picture of a fetus
you're showing people a picture of a
gestational Sac that's been expelled
with a tiny fetus if you wanted to show
people what a fetus looks like at the
age of 10 weeks in gestation you would
show them the fetus itself and you would
have to zoom in because it's a very time
you would have to use a microscope you
know this is the year of Our Lord 2022
we have plenty of medical Technologies
which are being put to Great evil but we
we can also put them to good use and
show what the baby looks like and it is
simply a fact at 10 weeks the baby looks
like a baby and has little fingernails
and little toes do you see the baby in
this photo exactly and that's what I'm
telling you and that's what I'm telling
you microscope so bring a microscope so
when we talk about so when we talk about
abortion 80 of abortions this is the
contents and so when we talk about can I
please Michael I allowed you to finish
now well I appreciate you allowing me
that but I guess I just I don't want to
move past this point your argument now
is not that the baby looks in a way that
you wouldn't expect the baby look your
argument is simply that abortion is
permissible at this stage because the
baby is very very small and you can't
see him in my photograph
no I am saying that abortion is
permissible because it is about the use
of the person's body who is pregnant and
I bring these photos because there is so
much misinformation put out about this
issue and like you well like you like to
say oh they react when you eat something
spicy they have little fingers and toes
when in reality the fetus at nine weeks
where 80 of abortions occur is hardly
distinguishable to the human eye so to
say that a living person sitting in
front of you with dreams and aspirations
and health situations and financial
situations mental situations that you
cannot possibly understand when they are
sitting in front of you telling you that
they do not consent whether it be
because they cannot or will not you know
endure a pregnancy you are saying that
the tissue within their uterus which is
primarily just a gestational sac and a
microscopic fetus that is worth more
than their desires about their own body
and you know when misinformation is
spread about this issue it is as if
these babies are dismembered and is this
very emotional and manipulative language
used when in reality that is not what
happens they've only been poisoned with
a pill and flushed out they haven't been
poisoned they've made the uterus
inhabitable uninhabitable so then it is
expelled
yeah that sounds like poison to me but
to the point you're making here Bronte
is you're saying it's misinformation
when I say the baby at 10 weeks in
gestation has little fingers and toes
are you you're saying that's
misinformation I'm saying that it's not
distinguishable and it is not useful no
I'm not asking about the human eye I
can't see your toes with my human eye do
you have them
do you have them I do have toes you do
but I can't see them with the human eye
because I have shoes on Michael but if I
took my shoes off they are
distinguishable to these now what if you
were five miles away and I couldn't see
your toes
five miles away because I'm with my
human eyes pressure five miles away from
you Michael no it is not what I am
saying is you can't see my toes because
they're within my shoe you can't see a
fetus because it is inside of a person
when it is removed from that person you
still cannot see the fetus whether you
are five miles away or five inches away
and you trying to use emotionally
manipulative language to reach your
audience and try to get them to vote to
ban abortion against the opinion of
medical experts that is why I bring
these photos because there are hardly
any medically accurate photos
representing this issue and instead it
is primarily illustrations and
propaganda that is pushed to manipulate
people into removing the bodily autonomy
from their fellow citizens when in
reality these fetuses are hardly
distinguishable to the human eye and we
should instead look at the person that I
can see in front of me and respect their
right to decide because what is best for
their she is a living breathing person
I've already said that the baby is
living it's not breathing it is not
autonomous so if if the if the pregnant
mother is intubated then we can kill her
because she's not breathing so that's
actually a good question so if we have
someone who's on life support what are
they connected to
uh tubes and breathing machines to a
machine right and a fetus is connected
to a human so when you use this analogy
there's two options either you didn't
think your analogy threw very well or
you think that living people are
equivalent to inanimate objects and
machines and so if that pregnant person
who is intubated and connected to a
machine If instead they needed to be
connected to a living person in order to
survive our current laws and medical
ethics would never allow you to force
someone to connect themselves to that
person to keep them alive unless we're
talking about the unique case of
motherhood I mention it right because
you said that in order for a person to
have a right to life he needs to be
breathing but that's obviously
ridiculous and and then the other point
here you've mentioned is that uh that
because I can't see a fetus at nine
weeks gestation with the naked eye that
he he isn't real or doesn't exist or
doesn't have a right to life or
something like that but I I just I I
wonder how you apply this principle are
you saying that the existence
or in existence of a thing
is dependent upon whether or not you can
see it with your naked eye
I am saying that even if you give a
fetus all of the rights of a born living
breathing person they still cannot use
someone's body to survive without their
concern that's a good that's a good
thing to discuss and I want to get to
that but I I don't think we can move
past this naked eye thing which just
seems to me so Preposterous you're
saying because I can't see someone with
a naked eye that that person doesn't
exist I'm saying that someone that I can
see and speak to standing in front of me
cannot use my body against my will and
neither can someone that I cannot even
distinguish without a microscope they
cannot use my body against my will why
not I mean they can obviously they can
that's what children do I mean usually
it's with your will because we're
talking because people generally consent
to have sex and children but even if
even if that were not the case you just
accidentally become pregnant or
something like that
it is simply a fact that your child can
and does use your body even if it is
against your will so of course that can
happen because we're talking about the
unique case of motherhood right and so
you are arguing that in no other case
can someone use someone else's body
against their will right unless we're
talking about motherhood right
motherhood so you only think that we
should remove bodily autonomy from
people with uteruses well I don't know
what you mean by bodily autonomy we've
just we've already accepted at the
beginning of our conversation that we
don't have and a total inalienable right
to do whatever we want with our own
bodies it's interesting that you say
that when you can't describe one
scenario for me in which someone can use
someone else's body legally no I'm
telling you that's that would be a
unique fact of mother right and that is
when I say bodily autonomy that is what
I mean I mean the use of your body and
decisions about what happens to your
body oh and so no no decisions about
what happens to your body that's
different because of the drug laws the
decisions when it comes to how your body
is used how if your body is being used
by another person yeah well or how you
use your own body right that would be
the case of laws against suicide and
drug use sure so that so then it's not
unique but if we're talking about it you
know a baby growing inside you yeah of
course that's unique to Motherhood
that's the definition of pregnancy right
so that's unique yeah I grant that right
exactly and so you cannot describe one
scenario where someone can use someone
else's body it's totally exactly and
that's what I'm trying to describe is
the only but so what the only people in
our society that you think don't deserve
full bodily autonomy are people no no
but if by bodily autonomy you mean
um
the only the only people who
can have babies grow inside them are
mothers
that is true I agree that's a fact of
life yeah that's true and those are the
only people in our society that you are
arguing should have their rights to
their own body removed well I don't
think they have rights to kill babies
right because you don't think that they
have rights to their own body well yeah
I don't think people have a total right
to do whatever they want with their own
bodies anyways we've already established
right but you don't believe that they
have the right to remove consent
to what do you mean to remove consent if
they don't consent to their body being
used you don't believe that they have
the right to remove that well I think if
you create a child you don't have the
right to kill them yeah I agree I agree
with that you don't think that if your
body is being used against your will
that you have the right to decide that
you don't want that to happen yeah in
the case of a little baby no I don't
think you have the right if you've
changed your mind and you say I don't I
don't like this baby anymore and I want
to kill him I don't think you have a
right to kill him just because you're no
longer consent right even though your
opinion does not coincide with the
opinions of medical experts yeah well it
certainly coincides with the opinions of
bioethical experts and it's certainly
with some medical experts but yeah I
don't really care what some Maniac
obstetrician except for 95 of OB gyns
who are the country in the world's
leading experts on pregnant people 95 of
them would you know help their patient
access abortion regardless of their own
personality you just told me a number of
them would commit murder even though
they think it's murder so I don't really
trust no I'm I'm telling you that people
who spend their Our Lives training to
care for pregnant people and understand
the complexities of pregnancy and the
lives of pregnant people understand that
regardless of their own feelings that
they cannot impede someone's access to
Medical Care and so I understand that
you might not feel like that's
appropriate but for me I would want my
doctors who train their entire lives to
be specialists in their field I believe
that we should abide by their expertise
and that someone who's not trained in
the complexities of medicine their
opinion should not override someone's
opinion I think we're talking a little
bit in circles now and I I don't think
that the Obstetricians necessarily have
the great greatest training in ethics or
you know philosophy or morality or
anything like that but so I don't trust
them on those issues or I don't really
trust the medical establishment on a
whole host of issues because they tend
to get get things wrong so frequently
sometimes egregiously wrong but
regardless uh I then have to ask
why has this become such a cause for you
you're a very prominent voice on this
issue what is it about abortion where
you say this is this is my issue so it
was actually an accident
um essentially I'm I'm in medical school
I am a woman in medicine and seeing the
rights to our bodies be removed against
the expertise of medical experts that is
a passionate issue for me because I am
trained and passionate in defending the
opinions of medical experts it was
medical school that started this yeah
and well I mean I've always been
pro-choice my entire life
um ironically I grew up in Texas and I
grew up Republican but I was always yeah
you grew up Republican I did I grew up
Republican what happened what happened I
became educated Michael oh did you I did
yeah I became educated and informed and
I realized that you know my opinions on
certain things were completely removed
from the reality of the issue and then
the deeper and deeper that I got into my
education like I said I got my masters
I'm almost done with my doctorate and I
realized that people who train their
entire lives to analyze this issue are
you know putting up a very solid front
and there's 95 percent of them that
agree that this is a we should have
access to this if the American Academy
of Obstetricians or whatever the group
is if they told you to walk off a bridge
would you do it
that's not pertaining to my medical care
well it would be depending on how well
you swim that's not pertaining to my
medical care that's that's not a medical
condition that is not a medical
treatment so it is an irrelevant
question if they told you that the best
treatment for cancer is to eat a
lollipop jumping on a pogo stick would
you trust them if they showed me the
science behind it then sure oh okay well
that's a little bit different because
then you're using because then you're
not just referring to the experts you're
using your own faculty as a reason well
the experts use evidence-based medicine
and so if they are able to show me the
evidence behind their opinion which all
medical experts should be able to do
then I trust them which on this issue of
abortion and abortion access they're
able to show multitudes of studies how
of why it's okay to kill a human no why
Banning abortion access actually harms
more people so Colorado University
actually did a study showing that
abortion Bans are likely going to
increase maternal mortality by 24 and
that abortion bans do not minimize or
decrease the amount of abortions that
occur they don't no really they do not
so what happened to abortion after Roe v
Wade was decided
what do you mean the number of abortions
we have the statistics right what
happened did it go up or down I mean it
depends because a lot of but a lot of
people because abortions become illegal
and they are difficult to quantify no
but Roe v Wade made abortion legal
nationally what happened to the total
number the total number of abortions
that are accessed through proper medical
channels decreased not the amount of
abortions that happen at people's homes
and unsafely and illegally no no maybe
maybe you misheard Roe v Wade 1973
legalizes abortion
so the total number of abortions that
happened after abortion became legal
you just said that the the sorry I
thought you were returning to that yeah
yeah so 1973 because you're just saying
that abortion bans actually don't reduce
the number of abortions legalizing it
doesn't necessarily increase it but what
happens no that's it doesn't go the
other way because people who desire an
abortion and need an abortion are going
to access it regardless if it's illegal
or legal safe or unsafe it has it has to
go the other way because the question is
is the regulation of the abortion so it
necessarily has to be it's going to if
you legalize abortion it increases the
safe and legal abortions if you ban
abortion it's going to increase the
amount of illegal and unsafe abortion
but it is what about the total number of
abortions though
that's what I'm asking about the the
illegal ones and the legal ones and the
bad ones you don't like and the good
ones you do like what happened after Roe
v Wade well the safe and legal ones when
Roe v Wade and this is the total
abortions
it stays relatively the same it's going
to increase in the statistics because we
can quantify the amount of people who
receive abortion access through medical
care but we can we can also quantify the
illegal ones too so why don't you why
don't you tell me Michael well the
abortions went way way up and they
actually doubled but but even to your
point on quantifying illegal abortions
and legal abortions you know we can
quantify the illegal abortions and there
was this Canard that went around that
before rothy weighed thousands of women
died every year from illegal abortions
and you're referring to maternal
mortality rates are being predicted by
all the dooming Loom people do they're
going to Skyrocket uh
but you probably know this statistic how
many women actually died the year before
Roe Vue Wade was decided from illegal
abortions in the United States I know
that about seven to eight hundred women
die every year from pregnancy
complications and I know that unsafe
abortions are in the top four leading
causes of maternal mortality but I don't
know the amount of people who died prior
to Roe v Wade from illegal abortions 39
in in the year before Roe v Wade was
decided 39 women and those 39 women
that's not a big enough number for you
to care no not but you know how many
women die from legal abortions that year
that same legal wonderful safe beautiful
how many 24. now if you look at the
percentage of states where abortion was
legal and illegal the craziest thing is
that your likelihood of dying from
illegal abortion or illegal abortion was
virtually the same see and I've seen
different numbers I've seen that only in
the past I believe it was 2018 only two
people died from complications from
um legal abortion oh well of course
because the numbers decline dramatically
the way that they got away with
pretending that five thousand women died
a year from abortion other than Dr
Bernard Nathanson admitted that he just
made it up when he was running narrow
but uh the reason is because decades
prior many more women died from
abortions because medical care just had
not progressed to that point but so
obviously since 1973 Medical Care has
progressed even more so you would expect
that number to go down for legal and
illegal the reason I bring it up is
because those scare numbers are uh I I
think they're just used as a kind of
propaganda they they deceive and that
the numbers usually aren't right and
they're dramatically wrong and and
because the number for the illegal and
the legal were basically the same
so my question for you is it seems like
you consistently want to find ways to
minimize the harm that is experienced by
pregnant people and I really want to
hone in on mortality right because you
think that death is the only negative
outcome of pregnancy no I never said
that there's a lot of suffering that
goes along with pregnancy exactly and
you think that you get to decide that
people who become pregnant should just
be obligated to endure that suffering
whether or not if the alternative is
killing the baby then yes so even though
the fetus that is completely unaware of
its own existence and is not even just
three month old man not even it was
unexistent right but a lot of adults
people aren't getting abortions at three
months and people who do get abortions
at three months it is largely because of
medical concerns or because they do not
have timely I mean three months out of
the womb I mean a three-month-old after
birth they're not aware of they're not
aware of them but they can feel they can
feel pain they can feel fear hope not
not at nine weeks they cannot not in
nine weeks it's questionable no it's
really not not from science because we
understand the neural networks that that
are required in order for you to
perceive pain and feel emotion and those
neural networks are not present at nine
weeks yeah well it's it's questionable
because people keep moving the
definition so you could say that a baby
at 10 weeks has a beating heart well
those it doesn't actually it doesn't
actually have a beating heart because it
doesn't look totally like art no because
it doesn't have all of the chambers of
your heart it is not an anatomical heart
it is the electrical cells that are able
to have an electrical impulse and so
again in order you know when you use
this language like the heart is beating
and it has a beating heart it has
emotion on the ultrasound many actually
that's a simulated heart sound because
it is an electrical impulse
because your heart sounds when we say we
listen with a stethoscope the heart
sounds are made from the valves of your
heart opening and closing that is what
creates that heart sound and when you
don't have the proper chambers of your
heart at that week of gestation many
times the sound on the ultrasound
machine is a simulated sound it can pick
up the electrical imp pulses but it's a
simulated sound exactly it's translating
a a represented into a representation so
it is true that a baby at 10 weeks
gestation is different in a way from a
you know undeveloped yeah right
undeveloped nonsense it's not
undeveloped it's just less developed no
it's undeveloped it's more developed
than it was at nine weeks right it's
developing sure so uh yes it's true that
you it translates that heart impulse
into a sound in some cases but where
does the sound come from the sound is a
representation of what is and will
further become the baby's heart but it's
not yet no it is existing anatomical
heart what's anatomical yeah but it is
not existing in the world it does it
does it's both of those things it is
electrical cells it is cells that carry
an electrical yeah it sells proper to a
10 week old baby that are that are right
that are different
in in some way from cells in a 15 week
old baby and a 10 year old baby and a 25
year old and again I'm going to continue
to repeat even if you want to apply all
of the same rights that a living
breathing person has do you want to give
the fetus those same rights nobody has
the right to use your body against your
will not a nine week old fetus not a 40
year old man it doesn't matter and so
when you want to remove the right for
someone to decide what happens to their
body you're arguing that the only people
who should have those rights to their
body removed are people with uteruses
who become purposefully or accidentally
pregnant they are not deserving of basic
human rights and that is what you want I
really like people with uteruses so I I
have no problem with them but when you
get to decide what happens to their body
when they are dying trying
so yeah we make all sorts of decisions
about how we should live but you keep
going back to rights which is
interesting to me because I I don't
think of politics primarily through a
lens of Rights but you do you keep going
back to writing services fundamental
rights to do whatever whatever I want
with my body in these circumstances or
whatever so okay if we're talking about
rights
are all rights equal are all rights on
this you know my right to have this pink
fruity drink here is that the same as
your right to I don't know drive a car
or something no I don't believe they're
all equal no okay so then there are
gradations of Rights some are more
important than others is there one most
important right that you would call it a
fundamental right the fundamental right
the right to your body and the right to
decide what happens to your body there's
no right that that precedes it
I mean it depends
what what rights do you think perceive
that please well it seemed to me that
the the right to your body
the right to do certain things to your
body must necessarily be preceded by the
right to life without which you do not
have your body or the ability to do
anything at all
well and as I've described Your Right to
Life does not get to supersede or
overwrite some override someone else's
right to bodily autonomy but I thought
we admitted that it did because I
thought we just agree oh you didn't
agree with that okay because it seems to
me if we're going to have any rights at
all the right to drink my fruity drink
the right to have a lovely conversation
in this kind of black room here any of
these other rights that all of those
rights depend upon the right to life
which is not just one right among many
but is it is the fundamental right and
so therefore if if rights are to have
any meaning at all
the right to life must supersede all of
the other ones and I disagree I think
that you have I think you have a right
to life but Your Right to Life does not
override someone's right to bodily
autonomy so why is that true because you
as I've asked you quite a few times now
you cannot describe to me one instance
except motherhood where it is acceptable
for you motherhood's unique but I'm just
saying what you are saying that the
right to do whatever you want with your
body supersedes the right to life it's
more fundamental than the right to life
and I explain to you why I think that
the Right to Life Is Fundamental and uh
more important than all those other
rights and I gave you maybe you don't
like my argument or something but I
think I at least spelled it out in a way
that's fairly clear and logical so what
is your argument as to why the right to
control your own body is uh more
fundamental than the right to life
because I think that if you allow the
government to decide that someone else's
right to life can override your right to
bodily autonomy that is opening the door
for a lot of terrifying things to happen
this is why you have to volunteer to be
an organ donor this is why you have to
volunteer to be a Blood Donor things
like that if if we allowed the
government to say that someone else's
right to life can supersede your right
to your body that is a pretty terrifying
amount of power to give to the
government we're speaking about I mean
you're talking about organ donations but
we're speaking about this unique case
right because no we're talking about the
use of your body right but but for
instance Bronte uh I have kidneys
I don't need both of my kidneys I maybe
I do to filter all these terrible things
I put into my body but I don't really
need both of them I could give them to
someone else but it would be wrong if
the government came in and said Michael
we're taking your kidney now because
Bronte needs it I might give it to you
voluntarily but I certainly wouldn't
want someone coming in gunpoint taking
my kidney away that would be wrong even
if you even if you were in Dire Straits
I wouldn't I still might give it to you
but I don't want someone taking it from
me and I don't think that I have an
obligation to give you my kidney right
because my kidney is for filtering my
blood that's what it's for right
uh in the same way a woman's womb is for
nurturing a child that is the T loss
that is the the purpose of the womb it
serves no other purpose so I don't think
that these the analogy that you're
making here is apt I think once again it
gets back to the unique status of
motherhood so the the same thing can be
said for your liver right your liver
well no one wants my liver well but your
liver the purpose of your liver is to
detoxify your blood it can it can
process alcohol it can process all kinds
of toxins but if I don't ingest those
toxins then my liver doesn't have to do
that job if I don't choose to Harbor a
fetus my uterus doesn't have to Harbor
that fetus just because your body can do
something doesn't mean that you should
be compelled to for it if you choose not
to have a drink
then your liver is not going to process
alcohol there's no way the alcohol got
in there but if you decide after I don't
know you know you had a crazy weekend
you went out here to Nashville met a
nice guy you would never do this but I'm
saying you know women of ill repute
would go out and you know they meet a
guy he's not so nice
anyway the next morning she finds out
she's pregnant really four weeks later I
thought it'd be very bad but mothers
know you know and anyway she finds out
she's pregnant she says oh darn I don't
want to be pregnant and you know that
that baby has no right to be in my womb
she has engaged in behavior that that
would introduce the baby into her womb
in the way that uh if you put the drink
down you will not be introducing alcohol
to your liver so should we then deny
Health Care to alcoholics because they
partook in behaviors that cause them to
have liver failure should we deny
smokers access to medical care because
they partook in you know in behaviors
that damage their lungs no no no but you
believe we shouldn't kill them though I
don't think we should kill them you know
or steal their livers or anything like
that I don't think we should go in and
kill the baby just because but you are
saying that you get to judge someone
based off of their behaviors and because
of those behaviors and because of those
behaviors you believe that they should
be denied Access to Health Care in order
to address the effects of those
behaviors and not if it's a drinker not
if it's a smoker but if it's a woman and
then sure now we get to remove the right
to her body and the effects of her
behavior no well and I I guess we're
again missing the point I don't think a
mother ever has the right to kill her
child in any circumstances so I I I'm
not uh suggesting that we single mothers
out here or that be very judgmental or
anything like that or deny anybody
health care I just don't think that
killing a baby is ever health care I
think that's a euphemism and that's
where you're kind of admitted at the top
no that's what we're talking about the
distinction between babies and fetuses
see and that's that's where you're wrong
though because when we we've talked
about maternal mortality rates we've
talked about the number one cause of
death for pregnant people maternal
brutality is still very low by the way
right do you know the amount of people
who have do you know the difference
between maternal mortality and maternal
morbidity
uh no it enlightened me so morbidity is
essentially unforeseen or serious health
effects of a medical condition so
maternal morbidity is when someone
experiences severe complications of
pregnancy and labor and I know that you
think that seven to eight hundred women
dying annually from pregnancy is too low
for you to care but you should bring the
number down right later but abortion it
but it is to pretend to resolve that so
60 000 people every year have serious
maternal morbidity which means there's
certain codes that they use and like
Insurance codes that they use to
determine whether or not you experienced
a severe side effect and some of those
codes are being having an ICU admission
or needing multiple blood transfusions
things like that and 60 000 women every
year are admitted into the ICU or need
both transfusions what have you that's
qualified definition of a of a severe
morbidity there's I think we're talking
about
or are we talking about certain things
that are less it's severe that's what
would be something so it depends because
it can be sepsis hemorrhage
um I think pulmonary embolism there's
there's multi there's multitudes of
different complications that we're not
talking about something like tearing or
something like that no that's minor and
that's not included in Sixty thousand so
that's my point is 60 000 women every
year experience severe morbidity and
that's not including the women who just
develop things like diabetes or have a
perineal tear oh well this is that's
actually a very important point that you
bring up of some of these problems that
go along with pregnancy because
something that the abortion Advocates
mention that often is not addressed by
the pro-life movement not not that I
think it needs to be but it's
interesting nonetheless is that the
United States is not the best when it
comes to maternal mortality we're not
the worst but we're not the best and and
there are lots of problems with it but
the reason for that of course is not
because of Any uh conspiracy among the
doctors or you know misogyny or anything
like that I don't think I think it
probably has more to do with America's
disproportionate rates of obesity and
heart disease and diabetes you look
especially it's not as though
complications of pregnancy are the same
across all demographics it's largely
concentrated in black women and the
reason for that it would seem to would
seem to me is that black women are much
more likely to be obese and have heart
problems and have diabetes and all those
things that are that that do factor into
pregnancy problems but that's not a
again I don't think any of that is a
good argument to kill a bunch of babies
every single year but that seems like a
health issue that should be addressed
elsewhere right getting people to
exercise put down the cupcake not not be
so obese and uh many pregnancy
complications are unavoidable and
unforeseen and so sure there are
comorbidities that make you more likely
a lot of them but but some are not right
right but when we live in a country
where Health Care is inaccessible and
inaffordable to a large majority of
Americans or a large percentage of
Americans yeah that seems like
overstating well it yeah it depends on
the statistics and it depends on what
you classify as unaffordable and
unaccessible because you know someone
can be you know living in a rural area
and it'd be less accessible someone you
know can be in financial situations you
know affordable it just depends on your
classification but I don't the thing is
this entire conversation you are very
fetus centered where I am very good I am
yes where I am very woman centered when
we are going through these scenarios you
consistently Center the fetus where I
consist instantly Center the woman I
want to consider her health her finances
her mentality and her body do you think
that I'm neglecting that yes yes because
you believe that the only people in our
society who shouldn't get to decide what
happens to their body
I don't think that people have an
absolute right over their own body
exactly and not I don't think anybody
that's where we disagree but
no you've said it multiple times that
you what you've said is you cannot tell
me one scenario in society where someone
can use someone's body against their
will but unless that is a hard labor in
a prison you know that would be one
scenario yeah well that that's in a
completely different topic because that
is you know essentially
when you described it and you said you
know give me a scenario where someone
other than a mother or I'm sorry a
pregnant person has someone growing
inside of them using their organs they
say okay I can't name any other scenario
you're right that's unique to Motherhood
you're right you're right it is unique
no I didn't say growing inside of them I
said tell me a scenario where someone
can use someone else's body without
their consent and you can't name me a
time hard labor in a prison well I mean
that again that is an issue in its of
itself we should we shouldn't that's not
rehabbing someone like that is
definitely taking advantage of a broken
system well but yeah but there are three
purposes to criminal justice I guess
this is a little bit of a pivot here but
it's not just Rehabilitation we could
all use a little Rehabilitation people
go to prison to get punished yeah well
it should be Rehabilitation should it
not I mean that this is a pivot and I
just think it's funny that the only
other scenario you can bring up is
definitely a symptom of a broken system
and so I don't think that's definitely I
think it's good to punish criminals
I think that's good I mean why is that
bad it depends on the crime but I I am I
mean again you know again
I mean this is you know going off in
into the weeds but I'm I'm naturally
compassionate person and I see the best
in people and I believe especially a lot
of crime is committed because of
circumstances that people find
themselves and I think I don't mean to
be this blunt but I guess I have to be
you have been sitting here
describing how it is good and moral to a
permit a system to exist that kills 850
000 people who you admit are human
beings every single year because of the
desires of another person that has been
your position and I'm not calling you
evil because of that I think you're just
extraordinarily confused and misguided
but to say you know I'm such a
compassionate person as I make it my
Jihad to to permit the killing of 850
000 babies who I admit are babies every
single year seems to me absurd see and
this is why I bring up that you are
entirely fetus centered in this
conversation and you completely
disregard the trauma experience
entirely right but many times that women
suffer in pregnancy but you don't feel
like it's worth protecting them from you
don't I know I think it's definitely
worth protecting them and giving them
the best medical care you can I just
don't think it's worth sanctioning the
killing of 850 000 babies giving people
Medical care does not you know minimize
or does not get rid of the trauma and
suffering of pregnancy you can have all
the medical care in the world available
to you and you still will experience
some trauma some pain and some suffering
throughout your pregnancy
right but if you do not consent to that
suffering if you're just talking about
rape which is a very very small
percentage of abortions oh yes so it
doesn't matter right it's worth it's
worth discussing but that is clearly a
the exception of the exception of the
exception it's not the rule consent to
sex is not consent to pregnancy oh yes
it is no it is not it's consent it's
consent to the possibility of pregnancy
it's not consent to enduring pregnancy
as I've said but if it's a sense of the
possibility of pregnancy then it is
consent to pregnancy
it is not it is not consent to enduring
pregnancy I I I don't even know how to
respond to that how is it not I mean
it's you you've just said that when you
consent to sex you are acknowledging the
possibility of becoming pregnant and
consenting to that
so you are consenting to that if I
if I consent to go to the bar
and I know that if I go to the bar
there's a possibility that I get drunk
and then I know if I get drunk there's a
possibility that I have a hangover the
next morning
then when I go out there to that bar
with the boys for a Rowdy Saturday night
I am consenting to that hangover that I
am going to have that will involve some
suffering and maybe teach me some
lessons in the morning right right so I
don't say how is that different with
pregnancy right I'll explain it to you
so because it's not that different so
say that not you just didn't have a
hangover because a hangover doesn't
necessarily require Medical Care say
that you had alcohol poisoning should
you go to the ER and then be turned away
because they're like well you drank so
you consented to the possibility of
alcohol poisoning and we have restricted
your access to medical care because you
consented to the possibility no of
course but again as we've pointed out
the issue of abortion is not the issue
of abortion is does not merely concern
the mother it concerns this other person
who you've admitted as a human being so
I think a more apt analogy would be if I
if I go out to the bar right and I wake
up and I've got this headache and my kid
just won't stop crying you know this kid
and he cries he cries and he cries and
but I got this throbbing headache and so
I say you know that's I got to kill my
kid I gotta kill my kid to shut him up
because he's crying too much and it's
really ah my body and my head is just
throbbing and I'm suffering and it's
just going to make me feel a lot better
if I kill my little baby who by the way
is exactly as sentient well exactly
sentient I'll even go further conscious
self-aware as the little baby in the
womb okay it's not it is of course no
it's not of course it is well you
haven't asked me how old my kid is it
doesn't yeah they're a born child who is
autonomous they are not equal to a fetus
Bronte oh my goodness what do you think
what do you think little babies are like
if you think they're autonomous so
you're confusing biological autonomy
with functional autonomy do would you
like me to define those for you oh
please do yes so biological autonomy is
when your bodily system can support
itself your organs can support itself
and you do not need to be connected to
another person biologically for your
body systems so maybe like a baby in in
the womb at 25 weeks sure when abortions
do not happen then when it comes
abortions that do happen then are
largely because of medical conditions
and so that doesn't work they don't
happen then or they do happen then but
they do not happen often then they are
like less than one percent of abortions
and yet for some reason states in
America like New York are changing their
laws in a hurry to permit abortion up
until the moment of birth
does not happen up until the morning
but Bronte they did change the law in
New York such that and they actually
changed the penal code such that
abortion is permitted in the state of
New York up until the moment of birth
that happened that is a
misrepresentation of the law that's
exactly but if you if you would change
the penal code such that if you kill a
pregnant woman it's no longer double
homicide if they could not more clearly
point out they could not more clearly
highlight through the statute that
abortion is permissible at any point in
pregnancy up until the moment of birth
see it seems that you consistently want
to demonize women and you want to feel
as though pregnant describing the law in
New York no you it but when you describe
abortions happening right up until the
moment of birth you are describing
someone who has carried this fetus for
like you know nine months 40 weeks or
whatever it may be and you are acting as
though those people are completely
unaware of the situation they find
themselves in and usually people who are
at that point in their pregnancy have
decorated the nursery have picked out a
name have went to prenatal appointments
things like that and so for you to try
to say that women are wanting abortions
right up until the moment of birth you
were demonizing them and you were
describing their behavior but women
aren't doing that that is not oh it
happens it's not something that happens
so then why do they keep changing the
law in all of these liberal states
they're changing the law to protect
women and protect women's access because
there's also so a lot of these laws that
are trying to criminalize women for
things like miscarriages and so
rewriting these laws all of that is
protected and and especially because of
the doe decision people don't realize
that the Roe v Wade decision was really
two cases row and doe right and do
creates this this right that protects uh
women's ability to have abortions for
psychological reasons for emotional
reasons practically until the very end
and so that already exists that was
already protected in New York there was
no risk whatsoever in New York uh that
abortion was going to be criminalized or
miscarriages were going to be
criminalized or whatever other
propaganda comes out so if you're
telling me that abortions do not happen
late term
why would multiple liberal Governors and
state legislatures change the law to
permit abortion up until the moment of
birth I'm not saying that I agree with
those laws but I also believe from what
I've read as well that a lot of those
the way that you're describing it is a
misrepresentation of the purpose of the
law but I'm also not saying that I
personally agree with those laws if that
is what they State oh good well that's
good why do you disagree with them well
because as I've said numerous times I'm
prioritizing the needs of the pregnant
person and 91 but if you're going to
prioritize the needs of the pregnant
person surely they should have the the
greatest window possible to have an
abortion which would which would be up
until the moment of birth I don't
believe so because I believe if you've
reached that late term in the you know
in the pregnancy then you know at that
point then the fetus is somewhat
autonomic it has the ability to be
viable and autonomous and that is when
their life Canon should be
um you know weighed heavy so post
viability you think abortion should be
illegal with the exception of of you
know medical concerns really yeah well
by medical concerns do you include you
know emotional distress or do you mean
real serious medical risks
um I mean not to Discount Medical or
mental concerns because those can be
serious but primarily physical wow so
you you would support a post-viability
abortion Bill yes great oh yeah
progress with the exception of of you
know medical and protecting medical
providers based on certain scenarios so
post post viability Okay so
then I guess I have to ask
why why is viability so important why is
Independence so important because you
know a baby who's born
a newborn baby can't do a damn thing you
leave the baby outside or even inside
for 72 hours the kid's gonna die right
that's fine that's functional autonomy
versus biological right but practically
it's the same thing it's not biological
and no biological autonomy and
functional autonomy are two very
different things but they're distinct
yes practically speaking they're the
same thing because if you leave the baby
who you say is biologically autonomous
if you leave that baby alone to his
autonomous self for let's say five days
even that baby is going to die that baby
has no control over himself or his
surroundings at all because it's a
dysfunctional autonomy so right and
that's really a distinction without a
difference no but the difference is
anyone can provide food and shelter to
that infant where only the singular
pregnant person can provide the womb for
the for the fetus that is where that is
where and you can surrender your
parental rights you we cannot force
someone to be a parent they can give up
those parental rights and that is the
same thing in pregnancy because you
cannot force someone to use their body
and use their time in a way that they do
not agree with do you think do you think
parents of of children who are five
years old should be able to just
renounce them and say go away
pronounce their parental obligations I
mean if they're incapable of providing a
safe home no what if they're capable and
they just don't want to be a parent it's
just their consent if they're not but if
they're not mentally willing and capable
then they're that's not a capable let's
say that they are totally capable it's
some rich lawyer with a nice house in
the suburbs two cars nice dinner every
night they just don't want to be parents
anymore you think they ought to have the
right to renounce their Parenthood it
that seems like that would be better for
the child
no but I wouldn't want the child to grow
up in a home where they're unwanted and
resented so yeah I think that they
should be able to give up their parental
rights because that doesn't seem like an
appropriate environment for that child
well if you're saying uh Child
Protective Services should go in and
take the kids away maybe there's an
argument for that but I just I guess
it's just this right part that you
because you keep coming down to consent
and rights
if you're saying that a parent of sound
mind really has the right
to abandon his own children that seems
crazy to me it's prioritizing the
wellness of the child I I would never
want a child to grow up in a home where
they're resented and abused because
their parent isn't willing to take care
of them that that's why should we force
a child to stay in that and we're not
talking about what is prudentially best
for the child I'm I'm really focused on
that's not that's not what we're
prioritizing the needs well it's not
this was not the topic of discussion
what I'm asking about is the rights
you're saying a parent has a right to
renounce his or her child again if it is
prioritizing the well-being of the child
I think that the government what if it's
not what if it's worse for the child
why a neglectful home I'm not saying
it's neglectful I'm telling you all
things being equal this guy this nice
guy and his wife you know good jobs good
money nice house they take care of the
kid just fine they just don't want to do
it anymore and they'll do it if they
have to but they just don't want to and
it'd be a little easier if they could
renounce the child I'm I'm really
focusing on this question of Rights
because I think that's where the
abortion argument really starts to
unravel you're saying they have a right
to do that again prioritizing the
well-being of the child if they're in an
environment in which they are unwanted
then that is not an appropriate
environment for them and I believe that
if a parent is unwilling to care for
that child appropriately yeah and I just
think you're not accepting the no I just
think that you continuously want to
ignore the well-being of people that we
share Society with you whenever I don't
want to kill them whenever I right and
whenever whenever I bring up the
well-being of people it seems like
you're like that's not the discussion I
want to brush this off because that is
what I do rights too and then when I
when I focus on rights you shift to
well-being and then when I focus on
well-being you shift to rights and so I
think you're trying to evade no no
because they're intermingled right our
rights our our rights protect our
well-being and our our rights basically
have a large effect in our well-being so
they're not two exclusive things we
decide what our rights are depending on
the way that they affect our health and
our well-being and our mentalities we
decide what our rights are as a society
so where do you think rights come from
this might help me to understand your
view on abortion where do you think
rights come from well it depends on what
kind of Rights you're talking about
because in a society we like our our
government is a system designed to
protect our rights that is that is the
purpose right that is the purpose so
where do so the government protects our
rights so where do those rights come
from
I mean I think it's a convoluted
question because essentially if if we
were cavemen we wouldn't necessarily
decide that we had rights right I don't
know I think everything we're a lot
smarter than we give them credit for oh
the only thing we know about cavemen is
that they painted on the walls the only
thing we know about cavemen is that they
were artists so I think they probably
had a pretty pretty good intuition of
these things right but I mean our rights
don't necessarily come from anywhere
aside from our own analysis of our Human
Experience oh so then we don't
really have any rights at all
the rights that we have decided on based
of the analysis of our human experience
we have decided that these are the
rights that prioritize the health and
well-being society and these are the
things that we need to protect in order
to prioritize the health and well-being
of society
my rights are just whatever I say my
rights are no our rights are what our
society has decided on on a large
spectrum and there's when we look at
this okay well then our society on a
large Spectrum has just decided that
abortion is not a is not a right and in
about half the country now abortion is
severely restricted if not outright
illegal and so that's those are our
rights so again 61 of Americans which is
I'm talking about the Supreme Court and
the legislatures right but that's that's
our government right and that was our
government was conducted by pure and
that was stacked corrupt corruptly when
I talked when I talk about society when
I talk about Society I talk about both
society as a general sense and then
society as also the experts as it
pertains to to that right in particular
so when we talk about 61 percent of
Americans according to the Pew Research
Center agree let me finish agree with
the ability to access abortion in all or
most cases and 95 of OB GYN said
regardless of their personal feelings
they would help a patient access
abortion so that is what I mean by
coming to a consensus as a society about
what is a right that should be protected
and both society as a whole and the
society or the group of experts largely
as a whole has decided that this is a
right that should be protected but so I
think you're ignoring the way that our
society is actually governed the Civil
Authority in our society has decided
that there is no right to abortion that
just happened the Supreme Court just
decided that which is in keeping with
the longer jurisprudence throughout the
United States and England and elsewhere
in Civilization and so that that was
how the actual civil Authority in our
society that governs us determined we
would live and uh so then I I would say
if that's your understanding where
rights come from you should accept those
rights but then you respond to that and
say no that's actually that doesn't
matter what the Civil Authority says
through our self-government because of
this one Pew research survey and because
of the Trade Organization for the
Obstetricians so
who is the we and we decide our rights
as I've said as I've said pregnancy is a
medical condition an abortion is a
medical procedure and so when I talk
about the experts and when I talk about
people who should be deciding these so
our rights come from the experts it
comes from society as a whole in
addition to the experts in society as a
whole is typically Guided by experts but
society as a whole well what what
represents society as a whole is it the
Civil Authority or is it no it's not no
it's because it's publicly the
government is meant to serve society and
if Society decides that something should
be protected and then they Lobby their
representatives and in self-government
the representatives pass new laws and
appoint different judges and the judges
make rulings about statutory and
constitutional interpretation
and in this case they've said there's no
right to abort but as I've said
I've said legislation is not a pro
[Music]
leave that abortions you're saying that
the way that the people in the our
self-government Express their will is
through a pure research survey not
through our elected representatives at
The Ballot Box on Election Day but
through some survey from this one no our
desires are represented by surveys but
we have abysmal voter turnout here in
the U.S and so what is represented in
our legislation isn't necessarily
representing the desires of the people
it should but it doesn't but you so I
don't think that our rights come from uh
come primarily from just what we all
sort of agree upon but even even if I
did you realize how absurd this sounds
you were saying that our system of
self-government where we go to the polls
and we elect our Representatives the
representatives they're there to
represent us imperfectly as the Fallen
World might do but that's what they do
there
you're you're saying that that is is not
the way to understand
the will of the people but just like one
survey of who knows usually these are a
thousand to two thousand people that is
the expression of the will of the people
even when other surveys contradict it
that seems a little silly right if
you're saying our rights come not from
the Civil Authority but from the fuel
Research Center that seems a little
silly doesn't it no it's it is very
clear as of you know recently that our
representatives are not properly
representing the will of the people and
like I said we have abysmal voter
turnout by the way who controls the
government
in what way right now I mean who has
Unified Government today a lot of money
we would be so as our government which
party
control well right now I think the
Senate is the Democrats our presidency
is a Democrat and then I believe the
house went to the Republicans or it
hasn't been called yet I haven't well
the Republicans will take the house in
January when they're sworn into office
yes but today we have a Unified
Government run by the Democrats and so
when you say that our government is not
adequately representing the people I
agree with you entirely but uh yeah but
we also have we also have a filibuster
which is essentially you know
kneecapping our ability to pass proper
legislation that is the will of the
people but the but the representatives
of the people agreed to have the
filibuster in the first place right and
that is a point of contention right now
that should be sure I'm just saying the
filibuster itself was an expression of
the popular will and the self but it's
not right now and it should be abolished
accordingly they can abolish it if they
want to but it just hasn't been done yet
by either party correct right because
yeah and I I just because the pilot you
might disagree with it but the
politicians do not abolish it because
presumably they believe it's in their
electoral interest not to abolish it
because they are accountable to the
voters and so regardless of what you
think about the filibuster nevertheless
if you accept the premise of
self-government Republican government at
all that expresses the will of the
people
right well also we live right now in a
binary political system in the United
States which our political Spectrum as a
whole society doesn't exist in a binary
nothing exists in a binary and so when
we only have one of two options it's not
going to accurately represent the
desires of the people which is a big
problem in our political system do you
call yourself a Democrat no you're not
what do you call yourself I'm more of a
leftist you you find the Democrats are a
little too weak
uh financially yeah I I yeah I don't
agree with all the Democrats do but I
believe it was Obama who said that
voting is not marriage it is public
transportation you aren't going to find
the one but you take the one that is
getting you closest to your desired
destination and for me that is the
Democrats in our binaries well you're
not a liberal you're a leftist I'm a
leftist yeah
you're a feminist yes
you know I find myself I don't know
maybe I'm going crazy in my old age but
I'm I find myself agreeing with the
radical feminists more and more than I
do with the leftists or I'm sorry more
and more than I do with the Liberals
okay elaborate on that for me well there
was a great clip that was going around
of Catherine McKinnon are you familiar
with her no I don't think so Catherine
McKinnon wonderful great radical
feminist
and it was her debating some
conservative over porn
and uh she made this point she said you
know
you conservatives some of you
conservatives are tolerant of porn you
think porn is no big deal and obviously
since the Internet it's exploded
everywhere and it's caused a lot of
problems uh and she says but you know
imagine if you were in your apartment
and you heard some guy knocking a woman
around oh every single wall abusing some
woman and and what would you do I hope
you'd go over to the apartment try to
stop it I hope you'd call the cops but
that's what you're doing when you're
when you're watching porn and this weak
conservative he said well you know but
people will have a right to look at
whatever smut they want and she said
what are you talking about you know
that's completely insane and the the
conservative said to her well well don't
you agree with that all these free
principles of just watching whatever you
want she said no because I'm not a
liberal I'm a feminist I'm not a liberal
I thought I guess maybe I'm a feminist
too who knew yeah
I mean are you would you describe
yourself as uh she called herself sex
negative
you know that's the kind of anti-porn
feminists are you the anti-porn feminist
or the pro-born feminist yeah because
largely are the pornographic industry is
a huge issue as far as perpetuating and
supporting sex trafficking and human
trafficking and so no yeah I'm not a
supporter of the porn industry as a
whole now as far as like can we agree on
something yeah and as far as like sexual
Liberation and the ability to you know
consciously and responsibly consume porn
I'm not necessarily opposed to that but
the large porn industry as a whole as it
supports uh sex trafficking and is
largely unregulated I am yeah is it only
the trafficking that bothers you or is
it
the women who are involved in porn
come from bad backgrounds almost all the
time and usually neglectful and abusive
backgrounds and they're very vulnerable
and they're completely exploited and
they're paid pennies and they're treated
literally like meat and then they're
thrown out two years later and it's just
the whole thing so ghastly right and
it's not uh that's not a matter of
trafficking exactly but it's still an
exploitation yeah but then you then you
just said that you don't mind people
watching porn in certain circumstances
right if if if the industry was better
regulated people were paid living wages
there wasn't this whole situation where
people feel you know pressured or forced
into that industry based off of certain
life experiences or certain certain
circumstances 100 of the time right well
not not necessarily 100 I do feel like
people can consensually and responsibly
um you know participate I mean that's
not necessarily what happens like I see
and I think that that is sort of
dehumanizing and I think right but
that's also removing the consent aspect
because there are a lot of people who do
do sex work responsibly and they do so
of their own volition so you so before
you were sounding sex negative like the
radical feminists now you're sounding
sex positive like the Liberals well I am
sex positive but oh I mean it depends
all right never mind I thought we agreed
on one thing finally I mean we agree
that we both do not like the porn
industry as a whole but you wouldn't
would you ban it
uh the porn industry yeah
I mean frankly according to the law it
already sort of is largely banned it's
just a few Court decisions kind of
screwed that up but yeah I mean I think
that things like only fans should stay
legal when they are run I think that if
it is run by the worker themselves and
it is there deciding to do something of
their own volition then I'm not
necessarily opposed to that but I do
think that the porn industry should be
banned or regulated as a you know as a
whole well that's good so people should
not be permitted to look at PornHub for
instance that's what you're saying yeah
I think PornHub should be shut down
because a lot of it is you know
unregulated and kind of there's a lot of
things on there too that perpetuate
abuse that perpetuate um you know
radicalist ideas of you know
objectifying women
um and so that yeah I definitely not so
does that not undercut a little bit of
your argument about bodily autonomy and
doing what you want you know in your own
bedroom with the blinds closed I mean if
a guy wants to go into his bedroom and
pull up some disgusting pornography and
uh do whatever with his own body you
know sex with someone you love as Woody
Allen described it uh
is that not a matter of his personal
bodily autonomy that he allegedly has a
right to I believe he has the right to
do that but like I said it doesn't
happen oh you do it doesn't have to be
done through PornHub there are
responsible and worker run but what if
he really likes PornHub what if that's
his that's his favorite one well we
don't have to protect his right to
access PornHub no I don't know we should
no that's good all right that's
something but only fans who think is
okay yeah I think only fans is okay
because like I said it is run by the
workers themselves and they aren't
exploited by an industry and they aren't
forced into certain things don't you
think that
pornography intrinsically is
exploitative and degrading I guess
that's my problem with it there are
other problems too I mean it's not just
the consent is what I'm saying because
you seem to think that the only moral
Criterion that matters is consent if you
consent to do it then it's fine and
dandy but I think there are plenty of
things that you can consent to do that
are not good
and are degrading and feed your basist
passions and enslave you and should be
illegal and are illegal even today in
some cases
yeah elaborate on that well like drugs
would be an example right I don't think
you have a right to do drugs but I don't
think you have a right to do all sorts
of things you know I don't think people
should have a right to cheat on their
wives maybe a married man can sense to
sleep with his secretary or something
and the secretary can sense it I think
that should be illegal and it was
illegal for a lot of American History I
don't think you would have a right to
that I don't think that if you uh are
under the delusion if you're a man and
you're under the delusion that you're a
woman that you have a right to chop your
Healthy genitals off any more than you
that you would have a right to walk into
a doctor's office and say Doc I identify
as a quadriplegic the doc says man
you've got problems you know you need to
go see a psychologist you know I'm not
going to chop your limbs off but then
that same man walks into a doctor's
office he says doc I'm a woman that doc
says wow oh my gosh that's so brave and
wonderful you're a stunning beautiful
woman let's get you onto the operating
table and cut off the Family Jewels that
seems to me Preposterous I don't think
anyone has a right to that I guess
ultimately I'm saying I don't think you
have a right
to wrong
well what we Define as wrong is
different between you and I because I do
agree in providing gender affirming care
to people because when you are in a body
that doesn't feel right to you and you
do not identify as the gender that
people perceive you as that can have
psychological consequences and again
when we look at Medical experts who
study this and provide this care they
agree that gender affirming care is
essential in order to prioritize the
needs of these patients what about Dr
Paul McHugh I don't know so Dr Paul
McHugh was a doctor at uh Johns Hopkins
and was the pioneer of the gender
transition surgery and was the head of
their gender clinic and so he pioneered
the whole thing then he found after a
few years that it wasn't improving
psychological outcomes he didn't find
that it was damaging psychological
outcomes in most cases but it just
wasn't really doing anything and it
wasn't helping and so if it wasn't
helping he shut it down and so he's not
only one figure in
the transgender Care Medical Community
whatever I mean he's he's a preeminent
figure in it and he says that it's awful
and we should stop the surgeries so does
his expert opinion color your views at
all no so in medicine we are taught
something called paternalism is
something that we should avoid and
paternalism is essentially putting your
own personal views into the health care
of other people so if you believe that a
patient is going to regret this decision
then you are going to you know prohibit
their access to this and as medical
practitioners as Physicians like we are
taught to avoid paternalism and acting
paternalistically is unethical so that's
an interesting use of the word
paternalism so by that you mean just
having opinions and acting on them no no
it is a specific terminology in medical
ethics it is not prohibiting your
patients access to Medical Care based on
you would give advice right but I don't
think you should drop your genitals off
or I don't think you should have an
abortion see and that is putting your
that is putting your personal opinion
that is unrelated to medical studies and
unrelated to proper psychology why would
you hold a personal opinion that is
completely out of step with reality
would you I mean I I just fail to
understand this distinction between a
personal opinion and say a public
opinion a professional professional
opinion yeah I just don't see if if
if they disagree the professional
opinion that you're supposed to hold and
your personal opinion and if they're
contradictory only one of them can be
true so if if the professional opinion
is true then why do you hold your
mistaken personal opinion and if your
personal opinion is true then why would
you give a damn what some lunatic who's
telling you to perform a lobotomy has to
say so a PR when it comes to medical
practice your personal opinion is
colored by your own personal experience
where your professional opinion is
influenced by evidence and training and
is your is your personal opinion not
influenced by your faculties of reason
and your moral conscience and your
ability to perceive reality true but my
moral conscience and my ability to
perceive reality is based off of my own
personal reality and my personal reality
differs from someone else's hold on I
thought I thought the purpose of reason
and
perception is to ascertain objective
reality it's not like the imagination
where you're just concocting your own
fantasies right so what you're telling
me then is that your faculties of reason
and moral conscience are not reliable
and they can have nothing to say about
objective reality so then I have to ask
why should I care what you think about
anything
well it depends on what you're asking me
my opinion on because again there's a
difference between personal and
professional opinions because when
professional opinions especially Medical
Practice are colored by statistics and
training that is going to supersede my
personal opinion when it comes to
offering someone medical advice so are
you saying you simultaneously hold two
opinions at the same time or or are you
saying that
you just defer to the Board of
Obstetricians on every question I'm
saying that I understand
you know that I need to avoid
paternalism and that although my
personal opinion and my personal
experience and my uh perception of life
based off of you know my own world view
isn't going to be completely accurate
when it comes to the life experience of
a patient sitting in my examiner so what
if it's it's 1950 you're you've just
graduated medical school you're doing
your residency and the the fancy people
in the lab coat say all right Bronte
here's your first assignment you're
going to perform a lobotomy on this
crazy lady and the crazy lady comes in
and you say you know I think it's
probably a bad idea to perform this
lobotomy I think scrambling up poor
women's Brains is not not good but the
consensus medical opinion the
professional opinion disagrees with my
personal opinion here would you just put
your personal opinion and your own view
of from your reason and your conscience
aside and scramble up the poor woman's
brains so does the woman is she wanting
this procedure well she's a bit crazy
isn't she but maybe maybe she said she
wants it maybe one day she says she
wants it another day she says she
doesn't want it I mean with any kind of
psychological treatment there's a lot of
ambiguity so in this sort of situation
but let's say let's say that she does
want it so in this translation we have
we have the privilege of you know
perspective right we in the 1950s you
don't have the privilege of that kind of
perspective so we understand that you
know medically lobotomies are not
appropriate but in the 50s we are
working with the evidence that we have
at the time and if the patient is
wanting the procedure and the evidence
and studies at the time support that
procedure then sure you would you would
perform the lobotomy even if your
faculties have reason because it was it
was controversial at the time right just
as abortion and transgender surgery are
controversial now and so you're saying
even if you because it's not only that
we learned in force foresight you know
or rather in uh retrospectively oh gosh
can you imagine we did these lobotomies
well everyone agreed to do them and then
all of a sudden we all realized it was
wrong no it was it was very
controversial at the time but the a lab
coat people said go do them
so I think the analogy is quite apt to
abortion and to transgenderism and let's
say you know I disagree with you well
let's just go to the lobotomy thing then
you know at the time as did many many
people in the medical profession that
lobotomies are really spooky and weird
and not good and you really disagree
with it but you're there there's the
patient the docs are telling you to
perform the lobotomy
do you really put your own moral
conscience aside in your own your own
rational thought aside and you just do
what the doctors tell you to do I mean
not necessarily no oh okay good right
and I also don't believe that lobotomies
are you know analogous to gender
affirming care and when we are talking
about because gender affirming care is
not necessarily controversial in the
medical field where the guy who invented
it says that it's terrible as you said
as you said it might not have improved
their psycho you know their mental state
but it also didn't necessarily damage
him personally but on the campaigns
against it
it's convenient that you choose this one
person who campaigns against it well he
happens to be the pioneer of it well he
might have been one of the first to do
it but in the medical field it is shown
that providing gender affirming care is
beneficial to the patients when done
with evidence-based medicine and
appropriately in the medical field it
was shown that lobotomies were really
good for crazy ladies and it was shown
with evidence and studies and papers and
very serious men in Horn Rim classes and
lab coats see and I just feel like this
line of questioning is inherently
transphobic and when you act as though
people who have you know gender
dysphoria or body dysmorphia or whatever
it may be when you act as though their
situation is equivalent to someone in
the 50s needing or wanting a lobotomy
you are perpetuating this idea that
their life experience and their opinions
about their own bodies is inappropriate
and wrong Bronte I just think I think
your attacks on lobotomies are
extraordinarily misogynistic first of
all and I think they deny the science
and the scientific consensus and they're
frankly ignorant because all of the
educated people with all the power they
say that lobotomies are really really
good and they're for women and they're
they're to make women feel better these
poor women are dealing with anxiety
hysteria actually is what we would have
called it then and and you're denying
them care that will ease their suffering
I think it's really awful I didn't say
that I would deny them that care if the
patient is consenting to this procedure
and the evidence and and the evidence
and the consensus of the medical field
as a whole is you know supporting this
kind of procedure then I would go
forward so you would perform the
lobotomy I'm not going to say that I
would prefer you just said you would
perform the lobotomy I would perform
previously you said you wouldn't and
then before that you said you would I
would perform a procedure if the
evidence supported it and the patient
consent it to it that is that is it
and in the 1950s the evidence supported
lobotomies I don't know enough about
lobotomies in the 50s in order to give
you an accurate response to that
question okay all right so seems to me
that uh
you your deferral
away from moral conscience your
admission that your moral conscience and
your faculties of Reason are purely
subjective solipsistic even they only
pertain to your own body and your own
possibly deluded view of the world and
so that's why you have to defer to The
Experts and the you know the people in
the lab coats and uh those people are
the ones who have the the ability to
make our rights anyway our rights in
fact come from the Academy of
Obstetricians or whatever and because of
all of that if the Medical Science
supported it and if the patient
consented to it you would perform the
lobotomy you would perform the gender
affirming surgery on the men who think
that they're women and you would perform
the abortion I just say humbly and
respectfully Bronte it should give you
pause if you're on the side of the
lobotomies I am on the side of gender
affirming care and reproductive Health
Care yeah and lobotomies not necessarily
lobotomies no because those aren't
analogous to gender affirming care if
you want to because it seems like you
are intent to use manipulative and
emotional language in order to know
because if you need to refer to
lobotomies in order to make your point
my point is that the scientists often
get things including in the medical
field we should be able to have a
conversation about gender affirming care
and abortion without bringing in a
controversial procedure from the 50s but
if you're if no we don't have to if you
have to no if you are not able to just
discuss gender affirming care and just
discuss abortion without bringing in you
know manipulative language and outdated
procedures then you're not able to
appropriately discuss this topic does
your your defense of well now
transgenderism but also abortion is
based on the authority of the of the and
The credibility of the medical
authorities and so I have to demonstrate
to you that those medical authorities
don't have all that much credibility
especially on a sort of bizarre and
controversial matters because
historically they don't have a great
track record and that's why I'm going
into the not too distant past by the way
it's not like I'm going back to leeches
and bleedings and all sorts of bizarre
medical practices that were accepted by
the experts for all of human history I'm
going back to a very very recent example
and showing you that those those experts
in the lab coats that you are deferring
to even for the question of Rights
itself are very frequently wrong but in
this case we have shown that gender
affirming care is beneficial to patients
who have gender dysphoria
of the surgery says it isn't currently
with the evidence that we have right now
we are showing that it is medically
responsible to provide patients with all
the information and all of the access to
health care that can benefit them in
their medical care and so that is the
topic at hand is it not is it not
discussing people who exist in a body
that they don't feel comfortable in and
modern medicine has the ability to help
them address that issue when you say
exist in a body or you say they find
themselves in a body or
who do you think they are
what does that mean exist in a body
our fellow citizens that we share this
Society with but who is
you're saying that they are distinct
from their body yes
so you you are not your body
what are you I'm
soul with a body
but you you are the soul
and your body is just uh it's the
physical manifestation what is a costume
oh the body is the physical
manifestation that's different well I
agree with that I think that the body is
a symbol of the soul I think that the
soul is a substantial form of the body
we agree on that but then that means
that the soul and the body are linked
right but they're not the same but
they're linked inextricably if you agree
as we just said that that the body is
actually a symbol of the Soul then you
don't just go about trading out the body
the body is not something merely to be
discarded the body is in fact part of
you to say I have a body is an
incoherent statement according to what
you've just agreed to because you would
say I am a body and I am a soul and I'm
this the the technical term for it is
hylomorphic being that is body and soul
inextricably linked on this Earth
right but that doesn't mean that my
mentality and my soul is accurately
represented by the body that I present
to the world so if you find a
discrepancy between your metaphysical
perception of yourself and the physical
representation which you acknowledge is
tied inextricably to your soul why do
you have to mutilate the body
wouldn't it be a little easier just to
change your mind and recognize that your
perception of yourself is a little bit
wrong if you're if you are if you're you
know you're a woman I think you're very
you know clearly a woman and if you said
one day I'm a man
well rather than my saying oh well good
go chop your body up shouldn't I just
say no and you're not you're a woman and
you're just uh misperceiving yourself
and you need to or misconceiving
yourself and you need to get your mind
right well you are then you would be
denying what I am telling you is my life
experience right because you would be
wrong according to you but you can't
tell someone that their life experience
is wrong no I can tell I can tell people
that their statements about reality are
wrong so why do you see the world in
such a binary why do you think that we
are men and women and there is no
Spectrum in between
oh well because I have eyes and uh and
reason so I can see you're a woman all
all evidence shows that you're a woman
what what makes me a woman well I
haven't uh you know I'm a married man so
I I don't have too much what what would
an abstract what would what would you
quantify sex to you well uh it would be
it would involve your
bodily features it would involve your
chromosomes it would involve your soul
it would involve
it would mean that you're not a man it
would mean that you're complementary to
a man and not identical with a man so
are you aware that medically your
genitalia your hormones and your
chromosomes do not always align with a
particular sex there are multiple
medical conditions in which your
chromosomes your hormones and your
genitalia do not match and do not fit
into this binding yeah there could be
there could be ambiguity of course right
and so what I'm saying is naturally sex
is on a spectrum and yes no yes it is
well there's such a thing as a liger are
you familiar with a liger like a lion
tiger it's a it's a hybrid of a lion and
a tiger but if we say that there are
some ligers not very many but there's
some ligers this would not deny that
there was a categorical distinction
between lions and tigers and the same
thing would be true you mentioned a
chromosomal abnormality let's let's say
Turner syndrome Turner syndrome is where
you have One X chromosome right not not
an x y not an XX video 1X well if why
don't we talk about Klein felter then
because that's that's when you have I
think two x's and a y yeah sure sure I
mean you can talk about any of these
chromosomals or or genital abnormalities
that's right there can there can be
certain ambiguities but in in that
expression
it's pretty easy to categorize I mean I
I mentioned Turner syndrome is it's so
easy to categorize people who have
Turner syndrome as women and uh but but
in the others too even when there's more
ambiguity you you can categorize these
things and so then we talk about this
distinction between sex and gender
and people say well sex and gender are
different so you might be a woman but
your gender by which people really I
think mean your soul I think you're
using the more precise language there uh
your soul might be the soul of a man say
or something like that but I I just
don't see how that would be true if your
soul and body really are linked and also
if it were true then why is it that we
would say that you then have a right to
mutilate your body wouldn't we then say
you have an obligation to express your
gender in accordance with your sex well
body modification is an entire industry
I can get tattoos I can get accessories
too yeah yeah but that has nothing
that's not the same porn in drugs is not
the same as gender affirming care and it
seems like you when they're not the same
but they're all bad I mean to you but
sure like porn and drugs obviously have
like that is a negative industry but
when you compare them to something like
gender affirming care you are coloring
gender affirming care I'm just saying
that that the the sex surgeries where
you chop off the boys you know know
Family Jewels that that's also bad
tolerance and
risk for people who are
current in being a compassionate moral
being and I don't believe that I get to
tell someone that they are wrong based
off of my interpretation of their life
experience right so so to get us back I
think to the top
I I sincerely believe that abortion is
evil because it is as you describe
ending the life of a human being
and so that's what I believe and I
sincerely believe that abortion should
be illegal throughout the United States
and this and I really would just request
that you not impose your liberal beliefs
on me and force me to uh to surrender my
political views in a self-government for
goodness sakes and force me to live in a
society where women are permitted to
kill their children I would just ask you
to respect and include and be welcoming
and tolerant of of My Views and identity
my identity as the correct person so I
respect your opinion as it pertains to
your body in your life that is the
entire point of being pro-choice is I am
not saying that you or your wife or
whoever should get an abortion I'm not
forcing you to get an ability right I
very clearly and being pro-choice means
that I respect everyone's ability to
decide what is best for their body and
for their life
it is thereby body and their life and
whether physically financially or
mentally they are incapable or unwilling
to endure pregnancy and labor and I hope
every pregnant person who's watching
this can try to understand if they had
to endure that unwanted and unsupported
how terrifying and traumatizing that
would be and you consistently Center the
fetus and I just want to say that I
consistently Center the pregnant person
I respect I respect women I respect
women and their ability and their
knowledge about their own body and their
own lives and I want to protect their
right to access health care what if they
believe that their baby is not a that
the fetus Is Not a Human Being you
respect that belief I mean well that
would be medically inaccurate so you
don't respect their knowledge I mean I
respect their belief but it doesn't make
it correct you respect mistaken beliefs
incorrect beliefs I mean if it doesn't
impose on my ability to access health
care and it doesn't reflect my life
individually then they can think what I
ever they want
but you respect it I respect their right
to have that opinion
but just not to act on it in public
I mean I don't understand what you mean
by that well you're saying you you
respect these views that are wrong but
we live in a self-government right we
live in a republic so the government
that we get at least in theory is going
to reflect what people believe and so
what you keep coming back to in these
questions of transgenderism and in
questions of people mistakenly believing
that the human in their body is not a
human being you keep saying well I just
respect your wrong you're you're
entitled to your wrong beliefs you can
but you know those wrong beliefs in a
self-government end up becoming law
but they must be evidence-based and
medically accurate and medically
appropriate and as you only respect the
beliefs if they're medically accurate
but yeah but you just said you respected
the woman's belief even though I respect
her right to have that belief
she can have that belief if she chooses
to have that belief as long as there's
no consequence of it Society right but
ideas do have consequences
I mean it depends yeah exactly like your
ideas that you're pushing on your show
do have dire consequences for pregnant
people as the University of Colorado
showed Banning abortion can increase
maternal mortality by 24 and so pushing
these medically inaccurate and
emotionally manipulative views on your
show and many others they do have
impacts on living breathing people and
they will lead to more harm and more
suffering of people's Mothers Daughters
sisters of women in our society well you
know because I'm a gentleman I obviously
disagree with everything you just said
but since I'm a gentleman I'll give you
the last word Bronte and I will leave it
there we know my position in the debate
I am firmly opposed to abortion and the
transgender surgeries and the mutilation
and to lobotomies and my uh I guess my
critics and opponents support those
things and people can decide for
themselves who is more reasonable I am
I'm sincerely really impressed with you
that you came out here and we're willing
to on the show and express your point of
view and I really I wish more uh well I
won't call you a liberal because you're
a leftist but I wish more leftists would
do it so thank you Bronte for coming out
where can people find you they can find
me at Bronte remzick on Tick Tock and my
website is behindingcurious.com all
right be kind and curious out there
folks I'm Michael Knowles see you next
time
[Music]
thank you
[Music]